ALL RIGHTS GOOD AFTERNOON
AND WELCOME TO TODAY'S HEARING
OF THE ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE
ON BREAD AND TAX WE HAVE TWO
OPTIONS FOR WITNESS TESTIMONY
TODAY IF ANY MEMBER OF THE
PUBLIC HERE IN THE ROOM WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY ON A BILL I
WILL ASK THAT YOU APPROACH THE
MICROPHONE AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME WE WILL ALSO BE USING A
MODERATED TELEPHONE SERVICE
THROUGH WHICH WITNESSES MAY
STATE THEIR POSITION ON A
BILL THE CALL IN NUMBER FOR
THE HEARING IS EIGHT SEVEN
SEVEN SIX NINE TWO EIGHT NINE
FIVE SEVEN AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS ONE THREE ONE FIVE
ONE TWO SIX YOU CAN ALSO FIND
THIS NUMBER ON THE ASSEMBLY --
REVENUE AND TAXATION COMMITTEE'S
WEBSITE AS WELL AS ON YOUR TV
SCREEN IF YOU'RE CALLING AND
PLEASE ELIMINATE ALL BACKGROUND
NOISE THIS INCLUDES MUTING YOUR
LIVESTREAM THOUGHT BROADCAST
IN YOUR SMART DEVICES TO
REDUCE THE -- AUDIO ECHO
OR FEEDBACK I ALSO WANT TO NOTE
THAT WE WILL BE IS ACCEPTING
WRITTEN TESTIMONY THROUGH THE
POSITION LETTER PORTAL ON THE
COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE FINALLY FOR
THE BILLS BEING TAKEN UP TODAY
WE WILL TAKE A NO MORE THAN TWO
PRIMARY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
AND TO MY PRIMARY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION OR WITH CONCERNS ALL
PRIMARY WITNESSES MUST APPEAR
IN PERSON THESE WITNESSES
WILL HAVE TWO MINUTES EACH TO
PROVIDE TESTIMONY ALL SUBSEQUENT
WITNESSES WHETHER APPEARING IN
PERSON OR BY PHONE SHOULD STATE
THEIR NAME THEIR ORGANIZATION
AND THEIR POSITION ON THE BILL
ONLY -- IT LOOKS LIKE
WE ARE GOING TO BE STARTING
AS A SUB COMMITTEE AND
-- WE WILL ESTABLISH QUORUM
WHEN WE HAVE ENOUGH MEMBERS
HERE I DO WANT TO ANNOUNCE THAT
-- MS BONTA HAS GRACIOUSLY
ALLOWED -- MISTER ADD VEHICLE
WHY TO GO FIRST BECAUSE HE
DOES HAVE AN OBLIGATION THAT
HE NEEDS TO GET BACK TO THE
DISTRICT FOR SO -- IT IS
LISTED AS FILE ITEM EIGHT AB
TWENTY THIRTY FIVE BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER VIET FOOD WHAT ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WHENEVER YOU'RE READY
K. THANK YOU CHAIR
AND MEMBERS TODAY I'M PROUD TO
PRESENT AB TWENTY THIRTY FIVE
HE TARGETED AND APPROPRIATED
EXPANSION OF THE UNDER UNDER
UTILIZED EMPLOYMENT CREDIT
PROGRAM FOR NBC SINCE
COMING INTO WORK -- EXISTENCE
IN TWO THOUSAND THIRTEEN THE N.
N. E. C. HAS PROVIDED CERTAIN
BUSINESSES WITH OPPORTUNITIES TO
RECEIVE TAX CREDITS FOR MAKING
NEW HIRES THAT MEET SPECIFIC
WORK REQUIREMENTS IT PROVIDES
THE INCENTIVE TO HIRE VETERANS
PREVIOUS PREVIOUS INCARCERATED
IN INDIVIDUALS PEOPLE WHO
FACE HOUSING INSECURITY AND
PEOPLE WHO HAVE BEEN UNEMPLOYED
FOR LONG PERIODS OF TIME
IT WAS IT WAS ORIGINALLY
ESTIMATED THAT THE N. E. C.
WOULD PROVIDE OVER TWO HUNDRED
MILLION IN INSTEAD OF CREDITS
ANNUALLY THE REALITY THAT NEVER
HAS BEEN LESS THAN FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS WITH THIS IN
MIND ALONG WITH THE NEEDS OF OF
THE RESTAURANT OF THE RESTAURANT
INDUSTRY AND THE WEIGHT OF THE
PANDEMIC MY AB TWENTY TWENTY
THIRTY FIVE WOULD EXPAND THE
NEC TO RESTAURANTS AND BARS
TO PROVIDE NEEDED RELIEF FOR
THIS STRUGGLING IN THIS INDUSTRY
THIS HOSPITALITY SECTOR AMOUNTS
TO NINE PERCENT OF THE STATE
WORKFORCE BUT AN ESTIMATE OF
THREE HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND
RESTAURANTS JOBS REMAINING
UNFILLED FEWER THAN FORTY
FOUR PERCENT OF THE RESTAURANT
APPLICANTS WERE APPROVED FOR
ASSISTANT FUNDING THROUGH THE
RESTAURANT REVITALIZATION FUND
AT EIGHTY SIX EIGHTY SIX PERCENT
OF THE INDEPENDENT RESTAURANTS
THAT DIDN'T RECEIVE FUNDING OUR
APPARATUS FOR PERMANENT OR
PERMANENTLY CLOSING MANY OF
THESE RESTAURANTS STILL OPERATE
AT HALF CAPACITY AS WE REBOUND
WE REBOUND FOR THE PANDEMIC
PROVIDING THIS UNEMPLOYMENT
TAX CREDIT FOR RESTAURANTS
AND BARS WOULD HELP ALLEVIATE
THEIR HIRING WELL SIMULTANEOUS
SIMULTANEOUSLY PROVIDING
FINANCIAL RELIEF FOR THEIR
HARD HIT INDUSTRY WITH ME
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT IS
CRAIG MISTER CRAIG ONE SISTER
WHO REPRESENTS A NUMBER OF
INDEPENDENT RESTAURANTS CRAIG
HAS OVER TWENTY FIVE YEARS OF
EXPERIENCE IN THIS FIELD OF
TAXATION GOOD AFTERNOON
EVERYBODY -- YES I DO
HAVE TWENTY FIVE YEARS OF
EXPERIENCE IN THE FIELD I WAS
PREVIOUSLY A PARTNER AT ERNST
AND YOUNG OUR PRINCIPAL OWN
ATTORNEY WHERE I BROUGHT IN WHY
WAS IN CHARGE OF THE INCENTIVES
PRACTICE OVER THE LAST TWO
DECADES I'M PROUD TO SAY THAT
I BROUGHT FIFTY THOUSAND JOBS
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA --
THROUGH VARIOUS INCENTIVES
PACKAGES IN THESE TYPES OF
PROGRAMS DO HELP AND THEY DO
WORK -- WHEN I DID RETIRE I
-- DECIDED TO ASSIST SMALLER
COMPANIES AND ONE OF THE
AREAS THAT I FOCUSED ON WAS
RESTAURANTS HOSPITALITY I ALSO
HAPPEN TO HAVE AN INVESTMENT
IN A BAR SO IS VERY FAMILIAR
WITH THE STRUGGLES OF THIS
PARTICULAR INDUSTRY --
SO WHAT I DO I USED BASED
ON MY KNOWLEDGE OF THESE
TYPES OF PROGRAMS I THOUGHT
WE COULD TWEAK THE NEC
TO ALLOW RESTAURANTS AND BARS
TO BE INCLUDED IN THE PROGRAM
I THINK IT MAKES SENSE THAT
THE POLICY REASON AT THE TIME
THAT THEY WERE EXCLUDED --
WAS THE THOUGHT WAS THEY JUST
DIDN'T NEED THE ASSISTANCE
-- THERE ARE GONNA BE HERE
ANYWAY -- RIGHT NOW WE KNOW
THAT THE RESTAURANTS AND THE
-- FOR THE HOSPITALITY INDUSTRY
IN GENERAL IS STRUGGLING --
WE AS AN AFFECT MY SMALL FIRM
ALMOST PRO BONO ASSIST A LOT
OF THE SMALL BUSINESSES JUST TO
GET THROUGH -- HOPEFULLY THE
NEXT COUPLE YEARS THE PROGRAM
IS ONLY DESIGNED TO LAST ANOTHER
THREE YEARS WHICH IS PRETTY MUCH
THE TIME PERIOD I'VE I STE I
SPECULATE THAT THESE RESTAURANTS
AND BARS NEED TO HELP -- I DO
FEEL IT WILL ENCOURAGE HIRING
CERTAIN INDIVIDUALS THE PEOPLE
I CAN SPEAK ON BEHALF OF MY BAR
THESE ARE ACTUALLY GOOD JOBS --
SOME OF MY BARTENDERS THAT WORK
WITH US TO MAKE OVER SIX FIGURES
-- LET MANY OF THEM HAVE
WORKED AT MY BAR FOR OVER
TEN YEARS AND IT'S JUST THE
REPRESENTED SAMPLE OF THE TYPE
OF INDUSTRY SO I DO THINK IT'S
A MEASURED APPROACH I THINK IT
HAS SOME YOU KNOW AREAS WHERE
IT CAN YOU JUST MAKE SURE IT'S
NOT ABUSED -- IT THE PROGRAM
WAS DESIGNED THAT WAY WHAT I
MEANT BY THAT IS IS THAT YOU
KNOW IT'S DESIGNED FOR CERTAIN
PARTICULAR AREAS AREAS OF HIGH
UNEMPLOYMENT IT'S NOT THE ENTIRE
STATE IT'S DESIGNED FOR HIRING
CERTAIN TYPES OF PEOPLE IT'S
DESIGNED FOR CERTAIN TYPES OF
WAGES AND IS DESIGNED TO TO --
AS WE WENT OVER IT LIKE CERTAIN
CATEGORIES SO I JUST THINK
IT IS A GOOD PROGRAM I THINK
ADDING THE RESTAURANTS AND --
IN THE BARS TO THIS PARTICULAR
PROGRAM WOULD BE A GOOD FIT
DO YOU HAVE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
OUR RIGHTS WITH THE MODERATOR
PLEASE OPEN UP THE MAIN LINE
FOR SUPPORTING TESTIMONY
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
TO SHOW SUPPORT PLEASE
PRESS ONE THOUSAND HERE
ON YOUR TOUCH TONE PHONE
AND WE HAVE NO ANSWER SUPPORT
AT THIS TIME ALL RIGHT AND
WE HAVE WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
GOOD AFTERNOON KATIE HANSON
WITH THE CALIFORNIA RESTAURANT
ASSOCIATION WHERE HERE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY THIRTY
FIVE ALL RIGHTS -- THANK YOU
VERY MUCH IS ARE THERE ANY
-- ARE YOU OF WITNESSES FOR
YEAH THANKS PRESTON YOUNG
FOR THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE HERE IN SUPPORT ALL
RIGHT IS THERE ARE THERE
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
IS THERE ANYBODY IN THE
ROOM THAT WOULD LIKE
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
AND CAN I HAVE A MODERATOR
PLEASE OPEN UP THE MAIN LINE
FOR ANY OPPOSITION TESTIMONY
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN CHAU
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO ON YOUR TELEPHONE KEYPAD
NO THANK YOU AT THIS TIME RIGHT
THANK YOU ARE THEIR QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CORK HAHA
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THE BILL
FORWARD -- MY MAIN
CONCERN IS THAT YOU'VE NOW
SAID IN YOUR BILL THAT THEY
DON'T HAVE TO BE PEOPLE DON'T
HAVE TO BE HIRED AT A HUNDRED
FIFTY PERCENT OF THE MINIMUM
WAGE -- AND THAT WOULD SEEM
TO INDICATE THAT THEY'RE
BEING HIRED AT MINIMUM WAGE
THEY CAN BE HIRED AT MINIMUM
WAGE IS THAT CORRECT THE
IN THE RESTAURANT INDUSTRY
WHAT WHAT'S INTERESTING ARE AND
WHAT THE BARS IS AND RIGHTFULLY
SO THE -- MANY OF OUR EMPLOYEES
IF I USE MY BARS AN EXAMPLE DO
GET THE MINIMUM WAGE BUT THEN
THEY GET A SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT
OF MONEY IN TIPS I DO BELIEVE
THE -- AND THAT'S HOW THEY GET
TO THE SIX FIGURE AND THAT'S WHY
WE WERE THINKING LIKE LAUREN IT
FOR THE -- THE RESTAURANT
INDUSTRY -- I ALSO DO BELIEVE
THAT THERE'S LIKE SIX OR
SEVEN POLICY REASONS ON
THIS PARTICULAR PROGRAM --
IN ONE OF THEM IS LIKE HIRING
A CERTAIN WAGE I DO FIND THOUGH
THAT -- ONCE AGAIN IN THE
RESTAURANT INDUSTRY THERE ARE
AVERAGE SALARIES WELL OVER FIFTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR FOR THE
BARTENDER PERHAPS THE PEOPLE
ARE THE -- THAT THE BARTENDERS
AND THE -- YOU KNOW I GUESS
IN THE CASE OF RESTAURANT THE
WAITERS BUT YES WE THOUGHT
THAT MAYBE WE CAN MAKE THAT
TWEAK TO ACCOMMODATE THAT WELL
BUT YOU STILL HAVE PEOPLE WHO
WORK IN THE BACK DOING THE
DISHES PREPARING THE MEALS
-- I DON'T FEEL COMFORTABLE
SAYING THAT THEY SHOULD ONLY
GET THE MINIMUM WAGE WHEN WE'RE
SUBSIDIZING THEIR HIRING -- IS
THERE A IS THERE SOMETHING
YOU COULD SAY IT WOULD
MAKE ME MORE COMFORTABLE
YOU KNOW I WOULD
WELL SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF
MANY OF THE RESTAURANTS I KNOW
THAT RIGHT NOW THOUGH IF YOU'RE
LOOKING AT THE COOKS AND THE NON
THAT THE NON DIRECT STAFF THE
WAGES HAVE ACTUALLY GONE UP --
THE THE PRIMARY DRIVER HERE
IS IS THAT THE CREDIT STARTS
REALLY THAT WHAT THE PROBLEM
WAS BEFORE THE CREDITS STARTED
BEYOND HUNDRED FIFTY PERCENT
OF THE MINIMUM WAGE WHICH WAS
TWENTY TWO DOLLARS AND FIFTY
CENTS AN HOUR THREE OUT AND SO
DO SOME OF OUR BACK OFFICE
PEOPLE ARE MAKING TWENTY BUCKS
AN HOUR SO THE THOUGHT PROCESS
ONCE AGAIN WOULD BE TO LOWER
THAT SO THAT WE WOULD BE GETTING
CREDIT FOR THOSE PEOPLE MAKING
IN THAT KIND OF THAT WAGE RANGE
RIGHT NOW WITH THE HAT MANY
MANY PEOPLE IN THIS PARTICULAR
INDUSTRY ARE PAYING THE MINIMUM
WAGE SOME ARE LIKE THE YOU
KNOW THE BACK OFFICE --
WELL I JUST GONNA SAY I'M NOT
COMFORTABLE WITH THAT THANK YOU
RIGHT NOW ALL IF YOU LOOK AROUND
-- EVERYONE'S PAIN
MORE IS IS OF LATE
LABOR CIRQUE SHORTAGE BUT I'D
BE WILLING TO TO WORK WITH YOU
-- AND ADD THAT INTO OUR
CONSERVE OUR OUR -- OKAY YEAH
I CAN UNDERSTAND FOR TIPPED
EMPLOYEES -- I DON'T UNDERSTAND
FOR OTHER STUFF THANK YOU
THANK YOU SO --
ARE THERE ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
I I HAD A QUESTION ALSO AND
AND IT'S KIND OF ON WHAT THE
ORIGINAL FOCUS THE THE YOU KNOW
OF THE OF THIS PROGRAM WAS
-- I THINK SMALL RESTAURANTS
AND BARS ALREADY QUALIFY
FOR THE PROGRAM RIGHT SO WHO
BUT YOU KNOW WHICH BUSINESSES
SPECIFICALLY ARE WE TRYING TO
HELP THEN THE THE
PRIMARY LIKE IF YOU GO ON THE
-- LOOK AT BARS AND RESTAURANTS
MANY OF THEM HAVE LIKE THIRTY TO
FORTY EMPLOYEES AND THEY'RE OVER
THAT PARTICULAR RANGE OF THE
QUOTE UNQUOTE IF YOU WANNA CALL
IT SMALL I COULD TELL YOU LIKE
MY BAR IS LIKE IN THAT YOU KNOW
IT IT ACTUALLY DOESN'T MAKE
MONEY THAT MUCH AND RECENTLY
HAS MADE ANY MONEY BUT LIKE WHEN
IT WAS AT ITS PEAK IT'S WELL
OVER A COUPLE MILLION WHICH IS
THE -- YOU'RE CONSIDERED SMALL
BUT IT'S STILL IN IN WHEN YOU
LOOK AROUND AND MANY OF THE --
I MEAN WE DO CONSIDER OURSELVES
AS THIS PARTICULAR RESTAURANT
AND WE HAVE PROBABLY LIKE A
DOZEN CLIENTS THAT ARE ON THIS
KIND OF SIMILAR BUCKET -- IN THE
YOU KNOW WITH TWENTY TO THIRTY
PEOPLE THEY'RE MAKING OVER THAT
MINIMUM SO THAT'S WHY WE JUST
THOUGHT MAYBE THAT WE COULD
JUST -- ELIMINATE THAT CAP
AND NOW ALSO WE ARE WORKING WITH
INDIVIDUALS AND MY UNDERSTANDING
IS UNLIKE IN THE RETAIL
SPACE MANY OF THE
-- RESTAURANTS YEARS INDEPENDENT
OPERATORS THEY'RE NOT LIKE THE
LARGE CHANGE THERE ARE SOME AND
THEN AS A RETAIL SPACE I MEAN
LIKE YOUR STORES AND SO THE
ORIGINAL INTENT WAS TO EXCLUDE
LIKE YOUR YOUR BIG BOX RETAILERS
AND PERHAPS LIKE YOUR LARGE
RESTAURANTS THE VAST MAJORITY
OF OUR RESTAURANTS THOUGH IN
CALIFORNIA ARE DOES THEY'RE
NOT THAT THE BIG CHAINS BUT
THEY DO GO BEYOND THAT LIMIT
AND SO THIS LEGISLATION WAS
JUST TRYING TO ACCOMMODATE
THAT LARGE GROUP OF PEOPLE
THAT GO BEYOND THAT SMALL AND
BUT THE PROGRAM WAS TRYING TO
THE PROGRAM I MEAN BASICALLY
WANTED TO EXCLUDE RESTAURANTS
EXCEPT SMALL RESTAURANTS AND
RETAIL AND YOU'RE SAYING THE
RESTAURANTS I GUESS HOW SHOULD
BE INCLUDED THAT RETAIL STILL
SHOULDN'T BE INCLUDED BECAUSE
THE RESTAURANT JOBS PAY MORE
IS THAT I MEAN IT IT'S IT'S
WHAT WHAT YOU'RE SUGGESTING IS
GOING SORT OF AGAINST WHAT THE
ORIGINAL STATED POLICY GOALS OF
-- THIS PROGRAM MORE I GUESS
WHAT I'M SAYING IS IS THAT
THERE'S A LARGE GROUP THAT ARE
CONSIDERED SMALL IN RESTAURANTS
UNLIKE LIKE THE RETAIL
SPACE WERE PROBABLY THE VAST
MAJORITY OF ECONOMIC ACTIVITY
IN CALIFORNIA IS FROM LARGE
RETAILERS RESTAURANTS IT'S AN
INTERESTING SPACE WHERE I GUESS
WE CALL ON ANOTHER ICON MEDIUM
SIZE RESTAURANTS IN MEDIUM SIZED
BARS BUT THE VAST MAJORITY OF
THE BARS AND MY CLIENTS DO MAKE
OVER THAT THRESHOLD THAT WAS PUT
IN THE ORIGINAL LAW SO YES I'M
SAYING TO MAKE AN ACCOMMODATION
FOR THAT GROUP YES IS THERE ANY
WAY TO FIND OUT HOW MUCH THE
AVERAGE EMPLOYEE IS MAKING THEIR
A CROSS SITE I MEAN I'D LIKE
A MEDIUM SIZED RESTAURANT TO
HAVE ANY OF THAT DATA AVAILABLE
THE DATA I HAVE WELL YOU KNOW
I WORK WITH THE C. R. A. ON
THAT I CAN COME BACK WITH THAT
RIGHT THAT WOULD BE GREAT OUR
RIGHTS AT ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
OKAY WELL THANK YOU VERY MUCH
WHAT WE'RE WOULD YOU WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE YEAH I JUST LIKE
TO RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE LATER ON THIS MONTH
ALL RIGHT I THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND -- HOPE YOU ENJOY
THE AFTERNOON IN THE DISTRICT
WITH YOUR WOMAN OF THE YEAR
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
ALL RIGHT ASSEMBLYMEMBER BONTA
AND THIS IS FILE
ITEM ONE AB TWO THREE
SIX THREE WELCOME
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS AB TWENTY THREE SIXTY
THREE WILL CREATE UNIFORMITY
IN HOW POSSESSORY TAX IS
APPLIED TO NONPROFIT MUSEUMS BY
CLARIFYING THAT MUSEUMS ARE IN
FACT ALLOWED TO TAKE ADVANTAGE
OF THE PROPERTY TAX WELFARE
EXEMPTION POSSESSORY TAXABLE
PROPERTIES ARE PROPERTIES OWNED
BY A GOVERNMENT AGENCY THAT
ARE LEASED RENTED OR USED BY
PRIVATE INDIVIDUAL OR ENTITY
THIS TAXES AND FORCED ON A
COUNTY BY COUNTY BASIS AND THERE
IS A LACK OF UNIFORMITY AND
CLARITY IN HOW THE CHARITABLE
EXEMPTION FROM POSSESSORY TAX
ON PROPERTY APPLIES TO MUSEUMS
USING THE FEDERAL DEFINITION OF
MUSEUMS AB TWENTY THREE SIXTY
THREE PROVIDES A CLUE A KEY
CLARIFICATION TO STATE LAW TO
REMOVE ANY AMBIGUITY SURROUNDING
THE EXEMPTION NONPROFIT MUSIC
MUSEUMS RECEIVE AND ARE
ENTITLED TO FROM THE POSSESSORY
INTEREST TAX WHEN THEY USE
THEIR FACILITIES FOR EVENTS
THAT PROVIDE ACCESS TO THE
MUSEUMS EXHIBITIONS COLLECTIONS
AND EDUCATIONAL OFFERINGS SOME
EXAMPLES OF EVENTS THAT ARE HELD
INCLUDE NONPROFIT FUNDRAISING
MEETINGS OR EVENTS FOR OTHER
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATIONS MEETINGS
OF GOVERNMENTAL AGENCIES
OR DEPARTMENTS CORPORATE
MEETINGS AND TRAININGS AND
OTHER FAMILY AND COMMUNITY
EVENTS MUSEUMS ARE CRITICAL TO
MAINTAINING A STRONG INFORMED
PUBLIC AND SUPPORTING THE RICH
SOCIAL FABRIC THAT BINDS OUR
COMMUNITIES THROUGH SHARED
EXPERIENCES AND BROADENED
PERSPECTIVES EVEN BEFORE THE
PANDEMIC CLOSURES INCREASING
PROPERTY COSTS AND DWINDLING
TICKET SALES BECAUSE MUSEUMS
TO HAVE TO RELY MORE HEAVILY
ON REVENUE FROM HOSTING EVENTS
TO KEEP THE DOORS OPEN AND
THEY NEED THE STATE SUPPORT
TO CONTINUE TO DO SO THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR I WOULD LIKE
TO INTRODUCE TODAY ARE TO
REPRESENTATIVES OF FROM THAT
AT CALIFORNIA OAKLAND MUSEUM
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN IRWIN
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
MY NAME IS LORI FOGARTY I'M THE
DIRECTOR AND CEO OF THE OAKLAND
MUSEUM OF CALIFORNIA AND WE
ARE THE SPONSORS OF ASSEMBLY
BILL TWENTY THREE SIXTY THREE
I WOULD PARTICULARLY LIKE TO
THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER BONTA FOR
AUTHORING THE LEGISLATION THE
MISSION OF THE OAKLAND MUSEUM
OF CALIFORNIA IS TO INSPIRE ALL
CALIFORNIANS TO CREATE A MORE
VIBRANT FUTURE FOR THEMSELVES
AND THEIR COMMUNITIES WE ARE
A MULTI DISCIPLINARY MUSEUM
OF CALIFORNIA ART HISTORY AND
NATURAL SCIENCES AND WE HOLD THE
STATE'S MOST COMPLETE REPOSITORY
OF CALIFORNIA'S CULTURAL AND
ENVIRONMENTAL HERITAGE OUR
MUSEUM IS THE LARGEST CULTURAL
INSTITUTION BY BUDGET SIZE
AN AUDIENCE IN OAKLAND AND
A VITAL EDUCATIONAL RESOURCE
FOR SCHOOLS FROM THROUGHOUT
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA BEYOND
OUR COLLECTIONS EXHIBITIONS
AND EDUCATIONAL PROGRAMS THE
OAKLAND MUSEUM IS GROUNDED IN A
BELIEF THAT A MUSEUM SHOULD BE
WELCOMING AND INCLUSIVE HELPING
TO BUILD TRUST CONNECTION
AND UNDERSTANDING BETWEEN
INDIVIDUALS AND COMMUNITIES IN
FULFILLMENT OF OUR MISSION WE
OFFER A BREADTH OF PROGRAMMING
WHILE MAKING OUR LANDMARK
FACILITY AVAILABLE AS AN AT
THAT LOCATION AND COMMUNITY HUB
AB TWENTY THREE SIXTY THREE
PROVIDES A KEY CLARIFICATION
TO STATE LAW TO REMOVE ANY
AMBIGUITY SURROUNDING THE
EXEMPTION NONPROFIT MUSEUMS ARE
ENTITLED TO FROM THE POSSESSORY
INTEREST TAX WHEN THEY USE
THEIR FACILITIES FOR EVENTS THAT
PROVIDE ACCESS TO THE MUSEUMS
EXHIBITIONS COLLECTIONS AND
EDUCATIONAL OFFERINGS AT THIS
TIME TO OUR KNOWLEDGE THERE
ARE ONLY FIVE COUNTIES ACROSS
THE STATE THAT WE ARE AWARE OF
THAT AND FORCE POSSESSORY OR
PROPERTY TAX ON SOME MUSEUMS
IN THEIR JURISDICTION MAKING
OUR SPACES AVAILABLE TO OTHER
ORGANIZATIONS FOR EVENTS IS A
FUNDAMENTAL PART OF THE MISSION
OF THE MUSEUM THROUGH THESE
EVENTS WE INVITE NEW VISITORS
TO OUR FACILITIES AND MAKE
OUR COLLECTIONS EDUCATIONAL
PROGRAMMING AND EXHIBITIONS
AVAILABLE TO A BROAD AUDIENCE
THEREBY FILLING OUR MISSION TO
ENGAGE ALL AGES AND ALL
BACKGROUNDS OF OUR COMMUNITY WE
OFFER GROUPS WHO ARE UTILIZING
THE SPACES VARIOUS WAYS TO ENJOY
OUR EXPERIENCES AND EDUCATIONAL
PROGRAMMING AND MANY TIMES OUR
EVENTS ARE THE FIRST TIME --
AUDIENCES AND CONSTITUENCIES ARE
INTRODUCED TO THE MUSEUM AS YOU
NO MUSEUMS HAVE BEEN ONE OF THE
AS SECTORS IN THE STATE HARDEST
HIT BY THE PANDEMIC MANY MUSEUMS
WERE CLOSED FOR MORE THAN A
YEAR ARE MUSEUM WAS CLOSED FOR
FIFTEEN MONTHS AND YET WE KNOW
THAT THESE ARE SOME OF THE
SAFEST PLACES FOR GATHERING
AND COMMUNITY CONNECTION
THROUGH ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
THREE SIXTY THREE MUSEUMS WILL
SECURE A PLATFORM FOR EXPANDING
OUR AUDIENCES AND EARNING
URGENTLY NEEDED REVENUE WHILE
PROVIDING FOR VITAL COMMUNITY
CENTERS FOR INSPIRATION
HEALING AND LEARNING AT THIS
TIME SO I THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION AND I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR AYE VOTE ON THIS
IMPORTANT PIECE OF LEGISLATION
THANK YOU AND YOUR SECOND
WITNESS SURE GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS JENNIFER
FEARING THE SACRAMENTO ADVOCATE
FOR CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
MUSEUMS AND ARE MORE THAN TWO
HUNDRED INSTITUTIONAL MEMBERS
AND NEARLY A THOUSAND INDIVIDUAL
MEMBERS REPRESENTING ALL SIZES
DISCIPLINES AND GEOGRAPHIC
REGIONS ACROSS THE STATE CAM
STRONGLY SUPPORTS ASSEMBLY WOMAN
BONTA IS ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
SIX THREE SIXTY THREE TO BRING
CLARITY AND ASSURE THAT MUSEUMS
ARE EXEMPTED FROM THE POSSESSORY
TAX ON OUR FACILITIES ARE USED
FOR EVENTS HOSTED BY NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATIONS COMMUNITY PARTNERS
OR INDIVIDUALS YOU JUST HEARD
THE IMPACT STATEWIDE -- THAT
MANY CALIFORNIA MUSEUMS --
WE'RE CLOSE FOR NEARLY EIGHTEEN
MONTHS DURING THE PANDEMIC SO
THIS IS AN ESPECIALLY CRITICAL
TIME THAT MUSEUMS ARE LOOKING
TO RESTORE REVENUE GENERATING
ENTERPRISES AND OFFER WAYS
TO ENCOURAGE PEOPLE TO VISIT
POSTING EVENTS IS NOT ONLY
ESSENTIAL TO THE MISSION OF
MUSEUMS BUT MAKING THEIR SPACES
AVAILABLE TO OTHER ORGANIZATIONS
ALSO ALLOWS MUSEUMS TO SERVE
AS INFORMAL EDUCATIONAL
INSTITUTIONS BENEFITING A BROAD
SET OF THE PUBLIC IN TWENTY
NINETEEN CAM SURVEYED OUR
MEMBERS ABOUT PROPERTY AND OR
POSSESSORY TAX AND DISCERNMENT
DETERMINED THAT THERE IS A
LACK OF CONSISTENCY ACROSS THE
STATE NEARLY TWO THIRDS OF THE
RESPONDENTS INDICATED THAT THEY
ARE NOT CURRENTLY S. ASK ANY
PROPERTY OR POSSESSORY TAX YOU
HEARD THERE ARE FIVE COUNTIES
THAT ARE STILL CHARGING THAT
BUT ACROSS THOSE COUNTIES THERE
IS STILL NO STANDARD FOR HOW
STATE LAW IS BEING INTERPRETED
AND THE AREAS OF MUSEUMS BEING
ASSESSED VARIES GREATLY SOME
MUSEUMS ARE PAYING PROPERTY OR
POSSESSORY TAX ON THEIR ENTIRE
MUSEUM PROPERTY WHILE OTHERS
ARE ASSESSED FOR MULTI USE
SPACES THAT ARE VERY LIKELY
USE PREDOMINANTLY INFORMATION
RELATED ACTIVITIES SO IT'S
CAMPUS POSITION THAT NONPROFIT
MUSEUM SHOULD NOT BE ASSESSED
PROPERTY TAX ON AREAS OF THEIR
FACILITY THEY'RE INTEGRAL TO
THEIR CHARITABLE PURPOSES AND IN
SERVICE TO COMMUNITY USING AREAS
OF THE MUSEUM FOR COMMUNITY
EVENTS WHETHER REVENUE PRODUCING
OR NOT SHOULD NOT COMPROMISE
THEIR PROPERTY TAX WELFARE
EXEMPTION THAT'S WHY WE SUPPORT
AB TWENTY THREE SIXTY THREE TO
BRING CONSISTENCY AND FAIRNESS
TO MUSEUMS ACROSS THE STATE AND
WE URGE YOUR SUPPORT WHEN YOU
TAKE THE MATTER UP FOR A VOTE
LATER THIS MONTH THANK YOU I
WAS PERFECT TIMING EXACTLY TWO
MINUTES YOU'VE DONE THIS A
LOT OF THEM ARE THERE ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES IN THE ROOM WISHING TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT YES --
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE NICCOLO DELUCA ABOUT
TO DO A BUNCH OF ME TO USE BUT
I FIRST WANT TO THANK -- THESE
ONLY WOMAN FOR HER SUPPORT AND
OF COURSE YOUR STAFF FOR WORKING
WITH US ON THIS BILL SO IN
SUPPORT IS THE CHARLES SCHULZ
MUSEUM AND RESEARCH CENTER THE
HUMBOLDT ARTS COUNCIL IN THE
MORRIS GRAVES MUSEUM OF ART MY
FAVORITE ITALIAN AMERICAN MUSEUM
OF LOS ANGELES -- THE MUSEUM
OF CINEMA COUNTY AND THEN THE
OAKLAND MAYOR THANK YOU RIGHT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY OTHER
WITNESSES -- CAN I THE MODERATOR
PLEASE OPEN A LINE OF MAINLINE
FOR SUPPORTING TESTIMONY
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN TO
SHOW SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN THERE AT THIS TIME
I HAVE NO INTEREST APART
AT THIS TIME ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES WISHING TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION IN THE ROOM
THE MODERATOR IS THERE
ANYBODY ON THE LINE FOR
OPPOSITION TESTIMONY
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN FOR
OPPOSITION TESTIMONY PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME
WE HAVE NO LINES IN
QUEUE AT THIS TIME ALL
RIGHT ANY QUESTIONS
SO YOU AND I HAVE BOTH BEEN AT
NUMEROUS EVENTS AT THE MUSEUM
AND -- CERTAINLY I DON'T
WANT TO HAVE TO PAY A HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS -- IN
PROPERTY TAX ON THE OTHER HAND
IT'S A TRADITIONAL TAX --
-- RULE THAT TO
THE EXTENT THAT YOU'RE COMPETE
WITH THE PRIVATE ORGANIZATION
AND THERE ARE LOTS OF HOTELS IN
OAKLAND THAT HOST THESE TYPES OF
MEETINGS NOW I CAN SEE
IT'S PART OF THE MISSION
IF IF WHAT YOU'RE DOING IS
POSTING NONPROFITS GOVERNMENT
ORGANIZATIONS AT A LOWER COST
THEN PERHAPS THESE OTHERS
COULD THAT PROBABLY MADE THAT
THAT MIGHT MAKE IT A BIT EASIER
TO DO THIS ON THE OTHER HAND TO
THE EXTENT THAT YOU'RE HOSTING
CORPORATIONS WHO COULD
YOU KNOW ALSO GO TO A --
THE HOTEL YOU'RE COMPETING THEN
PERHAPS UNFAIRLY WITH A HOTEL
AND ITS BUSINESS I DON'T KNOW
WHAT TO MAKE OF THIS -- I'M
CERTAINLY -- MY HEART IS
WITH YOU I'M JUST NOT SURE
HOW TO HANDLE THE THE SAP
TRADITION OF HOW WE HANDLE
TAXES PERHAPS YOU ARE ONE OF
YOUR EXPERTS CAN DISCUSS THAT
I'LL ASK THE EXPERT TO SPEAK ON
THIS BUT I WILL SAY THAT UNLIKE
OTHER NONPROFITS THE DIFFERENCE
WITH AT MUSEUMS IS THAT THEIR
SPACE IS ACTUALLY THE CAP
SOLUTION OF THEIR MISSION AND
WHAT THEY'RE INTENDED USE AT
THE INTENDED USE AND PURPOSE
OF THEIR NONPROFIT IS -- AND
AND I THINK THAT IT'S IMPORTANT
FOR US TO BE ABLE TO APPLY
THE EXEMPTION TO THE POSSESSORY
INCOME TAX B. POSSESSORY TAX
BECAUSE THEY HAVE THE ABILITY
THEY REGARDLESS OF WHO THEY
ARE HOSTING THEY'RE STILL USING
THAT SPACE FOR THE PURPOSE OF
BETTERING THE COMMUNITY AND
CONTRIBUTING TO THE COMMUNITY
SO I THINK WE KNOW THE MAJORITY
OF THE EVENTS THAT WE ATTEND ARE
LARGELY A FOR A FOR NONPROFIT
PURPOSES WHEN PEOPLE COME
REGARDLESS OF WHETHER YOU'RE
COMING FROM A CORPORATION OR A
NONPROFIT OR COMMUNITY MEMBER
YOU ARE ALSO BENEFITING FROM
THE EXPERIENCE THEY RECEIVE
WHILE IN THAT SPACE AND I THINK
THAT THAT ALLOWS FOR THERE TO
BE SOME EXEMPTION I ALSO THINK
THAT THERE'S A CHALLENGE THAT
THERE'S NOT UNIFORMITY AND THE
APPLICATION OF THIS ACROSS THE
ACROSS THE STATE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY FOR INSTANCE DOESN'T
APPLY THIS TAX AND AND AT OUR
-- ALAMEDA COUNTY IS SUBJECT
TO IT AND THERE SHOULD BE
EQUITY IN THAT APPLICATION
OKAY THANK YOU IF I CAN JUST
ADD ONE OF THOSE ADDITIONAL
PIECES OF LANGUAGE THAT WE
REALLY WORK TO CLARIFY IN THE
LAST COUPLE OF YEARS IS THAT
THESE EVENTS THAT THE ATTENDEES
OF THESE EVENTS WOULD NEED TO
HAVE ACCESS TO THE COLLECTIONS
THE EXHIBITION OR EDUCATIONAL
OFFERINGS SO IF THERE WAS A
MUSEUM THAT HAD A BIG BANQUET
ROOM NEXT TO IT AND PEOPLE
WENT IN AND OUT OF THERE FOR
AN EVENT AND NEVER SAW THE
COLLECTION NEVER EXPERIENCED
AN EDUCATIONAL PROGRAM NEVER
SAW AN EXHIBITION THAT WOULD BE
DIFFERENT SO WE WOULD BE HOLDING
MUSEUMS ACCOUNTABLE TO ENSURING
THAT EVEN IF IT IS A CORPORATE
EVENT OR A YOU KNOW A FAMILY
EVENT THAT WE'RE MAKING THE
SPACES OF THE EXHIBITIONS THE
COLLECTIONS ON THE EDUCATIONAL
PROGRAMS AVAILABLE TO THOSE
VISITORS AND PART OF THE
EXPERIENCE BUT NOW MY HEART
AND BRAIN CAN BE WITH YOU
YOU HAVE ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
FROM THE COMMITTEE ALL
RIGHT I I HAVE A COUPLE OF
QUESTIONS HOW CAN WE MAKE
SURE OR OR VOID THIS INCENTIVIZE
-- MUSEUMS TO CUT SHORT THEIR
HOURS TO THE PUBLIC TO HOLD MORE
EVENTS I THINK WE CAN SPEAK
TO K. PASSED PRACTICING AND
IF YOU COULD SHARE WHAT YEAR
-- YOU KNOW WE ARE
WE I DON'T THINK YOU WOULD
FIND THAT MUSEUMS WOULD EVER
ACTUALLY REDUCE THEIR PUBLIC
EVENTS I MEAN MOST OF THESE
EVENTS EITHER TAKE PLACE IN
THE EVENINGS WHEN MUSEUMS ARE
TYPICALLY OPEN AND MOST MUSEUMS
YOU KNOW TO TRY TO PROVIDE AT
LEAST ONE EVENING -- OF PUBLIC
ACCESSIBILITY OR THEY'RE IN
SPACES THAT CAN BE USED FOR THE
MUSEUM IS ALREADY OPEN TO THE
PUBLIC SO I THINK THERE WOULDN'T
BE THE INCENTIVE FOR MUSEUMS TO
REDUCE PUBLIC HOURS FOR THESE
EVENTS IT'S JUST OFFERS ANOTHER
IT'S KIND OF ANOTHER ENTRY
POINT -- ANOTHER WAY TO BRING
VISITORS IN AND MAKES YOU KNOW
REALLY LEVERAGE THEIR SPACES TO
BEST ADVANTAGE THROUGHOUT THE
COURSE OF THE WEEK I WOULD ALSO
ARGUE THAT THE INCIDENCE OF AT
ALLOWING MUSEUMS TO SAVE
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
DOLLARS IN IN IN PAID AT TAXES
COULD ACTUALLY GIVE THEM AN
OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE OPERATING
REVENUE AVAILABLE TO INCREASE
THEIR HOURS AND AND MAKE IT MORE
OPEN TO THE PUBLIC THAT'S THE
POINT AT AND THEN --
FINALLY HAVE YOU LOOKED AT
OF WITH MUSEUMS BE ALLOWED
UNDER THIS BILL TO HOST
A POLITICAL FUNDRAISERS
ABSOLUTELY NOT SO STANDARD
PRACTICE WITH ANY NONPROFIT
IN MUSEUMS INCLUDED AS THAT
-- AT THAT THEY CANNOT BE
INVOLVED IN POLITICAL PRACTICES
SO THAT WOULD STILL REMAIN
THE CASE ALL RIGHT WELL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND --
-- OF WE WILL MAKE A DECISION
ON THAT LATER BUT THE
PRECIADO -- YOUR PRESENTATION
AND WE HAVE -- I'M SORRY
-- WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR I RESPECTFULLY
ASK THAT AB TWENTY THREE SIXTY
THREE BE SET FOR A VOTE UPON
YOUR CONSIDERATION RIGHT THANK
YOU Q. AT AND THEN
WE ARE GOING TO MOVE ON TO FILE
ITEM TO WHICH IS AGAIN ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BONTA A. B. -- TWENTY
EIGHT EIGHTY I UNDERSTAND --
YOU ARE GOING TO HAVE A
DIFFERENT SET OF WITNESSES
PLEASE WHENEVER YOU'RE READY
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS AB TWENTY EIGHT
EIGHTY WILL PROVIDE IMPORTANT
SUPPLEMENTAL FUNDING FOR
CALTRANS BY USING VOLUNTARY
CONTRIBUTIONS AND STATE TAX
CREDITS SPECIFICALLY AB TWENTY
EIGHT EIGHTY WOULD EXTEND THE
COLLEGE ACCESS TAX CREDIT FUND
SUNSET DATE FROM TWENTY TWENTY
THREE TO TWENTY TWENTY EIGHT AND
ALLOW THE CALIFORNIA EDUCATIONAL
FACILITIES AUTHORITY TO CONDUCT
OUTREACH AND MARKETING TO
INCREASE SUBSCRIPTION TO THE
PROGRAM IN ORDER TO MAKE IT
MORE SUCCESSFUL THE FUND ALLOWS
INDIVIDUALS INSURANCE COMPANIES
AND BUSINESSES TO CLAIM A
TAX CREDIT EQUAL TO FIFTY
PERCENT OF THEIR CHARITABLE
CONTRIBUTIONS MADE TO THE FUND
CONTRIBUTIONS TO THE FINAL
GO TOWARDS CAL GRANT TO BE
CURRENTLY WHICH CAN BE USED BY
STUDENTS TO HELP COVER LIVING
EXPENSES TRANSPORTATION COST
SUPPLIES AND BOOKS THE TOTAL
TO GO GOING TOWARDS THE TOTAL
COST OF ATTENDANCE OF A COLLEGE
EDUCATION WE KNOW IT'S FAR TOO
EXPENSIVE RIGHT NOW EXTENDING
THE SUNSET DATE FOR THE COLLEGE
ACCESS TAX CREDIT FUND MEANS
MORE TIME FOR TAXPAYERS TO LEARN
ABOUT THE FUND AND STUDENTS
WILL BE ABLE TO RECEIVE HIGHER
CAL GRANT AWARDS THANK YOU
AND AS WITNESSES FOR TODAY WITH
ME I HAVE CASEY O'CONNOR WITH
THE OFFICE OF STATE TREASURER
FIONA MA A SPONSOR OF THE BILL
AND FRANK MOORE THE DIRECTOR
OF CALIFORNIA EDUCATIONAL
FACILITIES AUTHORITY ALL RIGHT
GOOD AFTERNOON AND I'LL I'LL
JUST REMIND YOU OF TWO MINUTES
FOR TESTIMONY EACH ARE IN
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE I'M CASEY
O'CONNOR LEGISLATIVE DIRECTOR
FOR STATE TREASURER FIONA MA
THE SPONSOR OF THIS BILL IN HER
CAPACITY AS THE CHAIR OF THE
CALIFORNIA EDUCATION FACILITIES
AUTHORITY ALSO KNOWN AS SIVA
SO THE SOMEONE COVERED A LOT OF
WHAT THE GRANT DOES I'LL COVER
WHAT SEE IF IT DOES SIFA IS
RESPONSIBLE FOR ADMINISTERING
THE FUND ALLOCATING IN
CERTIFYING THE TAX CREDITS AND
PROVIDING CERTIFICATIONS TO FTP
IN THE DEPARTMENT OF INSURANCE
FOR THOSE CREDITS IN TAXABLE
YEAR TWENTY EIGHTEEN AS A RESULT
OF FEDERAL TAX CODE CHANGES
CONTRIBUTIONS DRAMATICALLY ROSE
DRAMATICALLY AS TAXPAYERS SO
OUGHT TO GET THEIR APPLICATIONS
IN BEFORE THE LAW MADE IT MORE
DIFFICULT TO CLAIM A DEDUCTION
FOR CHARITABLE CONTRIBUTIONS AND
TAX WILL YEAR TWENTY NINETEEN
CONTRIBUTIONS FELL PRECIPITOUSLY
BUT SINCE THAT YOU'RE OF DEADLY
INCREASED CUMULATIVE TRANSFERS
TO THE STUDENT AID COMMISSION
SINCE INCEPTION TOTAL OVER
TWENTY ONE MILLION DOLLARS WHICH
WILL ALLOW FOR AN INCREASE IN
THE CAP IN THE BASE CAL GRANT
BE AWARD FOR APPROXIMATELY TWO
HUNDRED NINETY ONE THOUSAND
STUDENTS EXTENDING THE PROGRAM
BY FIVE YEARS ENABLING C. BUT
YOU SOME OF THE FUND TO PAY
FOR OUT REACH WILL ENABLE IT
TO DEVELOP A COMPREHENSIVE
OUTREACH PROGRAM AND TO INCREASE
CONTRIBUTIONS A PORTION OF THESE
CONTRIBUTIONS WILL CONTINUE TO
GO TOWARDS CAL GRANT BE ACCESS
AWARDS WE ARE AWARE THE ANNUAL
CONFUSION CONTRIBUTIONS TO THE
FUND HAVE DECLINED SINCE TWENTY
FOURTEEN FROM A HIGH OF THIRTEEN
POINT EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS
IN TWENTY FIFTEEN TO A LOW OF
EIGHT HUNDRED EIGHT THOUSAND
DOLLARS IN TWENTY NINETEEN
INTERVIEWS WITH ACCOUNTING FIRMS
AND PROFESSIONAL ORGANIZATIONS
INDICATE THAT THIS DECLINE WAS
PARTIALLY DUE TO THE FEDERAL
TAX CUTS AND JOBS ACT OF TWENTY
SEVENTEEN WHICH INCREASE THE
FEDERAL STANDARD DEDUCTION
ELIMINATED OR RESTRICTED MANY
ITEMIZED DEDUCTIONS SO TAXPAYERS
FIND THAT FEDERAL DEDUCTION MORE
VALUABLE THEN THAT'S THE STATE
DEDUCTION AND WHEN THERE IS NO
BENEFIT FOR TRAVEL CONTRIBUTIONS
AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL THAT MAY
BE LESS LIKELY THEY MAY BE
LESS LIKELY TO CONTRIBUTE AND
ALTHOUGH THESE CONTRIBUTIONS
HAVE DECREASED OVER THE YEARS
THERE'S STILL A BENEFIT TO THE
CAL CAN'T BE PROGRAM FUND THE
FIND ALMOST ONE MILLION DOLLARS
WAS CONTRIBUTED TO THE FUND IN
TWENTY TWENTY AND IT DID SEE AN
INCREASE IN THE TAX WILL YEAR
TWENTY TWENTY ONE OVER A MILLION
DOLLARS IN ANNUAL CONTRIBUTIONS
AS WE CONTINUE TO SEE FINANCIAL
RAMIFICATIONS FROM THE PANDEMIC
WE MUST ENSURE WE NOT ONLY HAVE
EVERY TOOL KIT AT OUR DISPOSAL
TO HELP STUDENTS ACHIEVE THEIR
HIGHER EDUCATION ASPIRATIONS
BUT STRENGTH IN THESE TOOLS --
WE DO HAVE TO ACHIEVE MAXIMUM
POTENTIAL FOR SUCCESS WE HAVE
SEEN IN OTHER PROGRAMS UNDER
THE STATE TREASURER'S OFFICE
A CORRELATION IN ACCOUNTS
OPENED OR PROGRAMS UTILIZE
TIED DIRECTLY TO MARKETING
AND OUTREACH FOR EXAMPLE IN
TWENTY TWENTY ONE A ONE MONTH
OFF SET UP WITH A ONE ONE ALSO
THAT OUR SCHOLARS YOUR FIVE
TWO NINE COUNCIL A SIXTY TWO
PERCENT CORRELATION AND DIRECT
OUTREACH MARKETING LEADING TO
AN UPTICK IN ACCOUNTS OPENING
WE FEEL OUR STUDENTS DESERVE
THAT SAME CHANCE TO MAKE THE
COLLEGE ACCESS TAX CREDIT
PROGRAM AS SUCCESSFUL AS IT
CAN BE WE SAW SIMILAR NUMBERS
IN OUR CAL ABLE ACCOUNTS
OPENING WHEN WE ARE INCREASED
CORRELATION TO MARKETING SO
FOR THESE REASONS THE TREASURE
IS PROUD TO SPONSOR AB TWENTY
EIGHT EIGHTY SHE VERY MUCH WANTS
TO THANK SOMEONE A BUNCH OF
HER LEADERSHIP HERE AND WE --
WITH ME TODAY'S FRANK MORE HELP
ANSWER ANY TECHNICAL QUESTIONS
ANYONE MAY HAVE ABOUT SEE
FULL OR THE PROGRAM THANK YOU
ALL RIGHT SO MISS MORE
YOU DON'T HAVE ANY TESTIMONY
I'M NOT PREPARED TESTIMONY OKAY
THAT'S YOUR ANSWER QUESTIONS FOR
YOU ON TUESDAY OKAY WELL THEN WE
SHOULD BE GIVING YOU THE WHOLE
FOUR MINUTES YET TALK REALLY
FAST AYE TIPS AYE TALK QUICKLY
SO I THINK -- OKAY IT ALL
WORKED OUT FINE -- DO WE HAVE
ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN THE
ROOM WISHING TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
ALL RIGHT -- CAN I HAVE
THE MODERATOR PLEASE OPEN
THE MAIN TELEPHONE LINE
FOR SUPPORTING WITNESSES
PLEASE REPORT PLEASE PRESS
ONE TO VERIFY YOUR FAULT LINES
THE FINAL GO TO IS THE LINE
NUMBER EIGHTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD YOUR LINE IS OPEN
AGAIN LINE EIGHTEEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN
ONE EIGHTY
NO ONE LINE WOULD
YOU PLEASE GO AHEAD
IT KEEPS CHANGING ALL RIGHT
DO WE HAVE ANY -- -- SPEAKERS
IN OPPOSITION IN THE ROOM
L. MODERATOR DO WE
HAVE ANY SPEAKERS IN
OPPOSITION ON THE LINE
AGAIN IF THEY WISH TO
PUT OPPOSITION PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO THIS TIME
CAN ONE MAN GENERAL PROPOSITION
AND NO WONDER QUEUED UP
FOR OPPOSITION I THANK THE
GRANT ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE
OKAY THEN I HAVE OF ONE QUESTION
I GUESS FOR A AND M'S O'CONNOR
YOU KNOW AS YOU MENTIONED WHEN
THE OF FEDERAL TAX LAW CHANGED
WE REALLY SAW CONTRIBUTIONS
-- THAT SHRINK BECAUSE THERE
IS OBVIOUSLY NOT AS MUCH --
-- INCENTIVE TO BE CONTRIBUTING
SO AT WHAT POINT --
TO ADMINISTRATIVE FEES OUTWEIGH
OF WHAT YOU'RE COLLECTING FOR
CAL GRANT SURE AND --
ALL START OFF IN A FRANK WANTS
TO NEW ONES ANYTHING I'LL TURN
OVER TO HIM BUT ON AVERAGE SEES
AS ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS ARE
ROUGHLY THIRTY SEVEN THOUSAND
DOLLARS ANNUALLY BETWEEN TWENTY
SIXTEEN WE WERE FIRST ALLOWED
TO START RECOUPING OUR COST IN
TWENTY TWENTY ONE -- ADMISSION
COSTS ARE RELATIVELY LOW FOR
US AND MR IN THE FUND IS ONLY
ONE OF PART OF SIFA STAFF'S
JOB SIVA ALSO ADMINISTERS OTHER
PROGRAMS AND THEIR PRIMARY
JOBS ARE LOANS AND PONDERED
MINISTRATION SO I THINK THAT
THE COSTS ARE RELATIVELY SMALL
FOR US TO AT LEAST ATTEMPT THIS
FOR FIVE YEARS WITH THE CORRECT
MARKETING OUT REACH ALIGNED WITH
THIS BECAUSE EVEN IF FOR EXAMPLE
TWENTY DOLLARS ADDED ON TO THE
BASE RIGHT NOW THAT IS PARKING
FOR STUDENTS THAT IS A BOOK OF
THE SYLLABUS IS A REAL NUMBERS
STUDENTS ARE FACING SO I THINK
-- ESPECIALLY THE PANDEMIC IT'S
IMPORTANT FOR US TO TRY IT WITH
A RELATIVELY LOW COST BUT FRANK
DID YOU HAVE ANYTHING TO ELDEST
ACTUALLY JUMP IN AND SHARE
THAT AT THIRTY SEVEN THOUSAND
DOLLARS A YEAR -- FOR OPERATING
COSTS IN ORDER TO BE ABLE TO
ENSURE A ONE POINT TWO MILLION
DOLLARS ARE CONTRIBUTED TO THE
FUND AT TO IMPACT A HUNDRED
AND SEVENTY NINE THOUSAND CAL
GRANT RECIPIENTS THAT FEELS
LIKE A VERY GOOD RETURN ON
INVESTMENT AND I'D LIKE TO
ADD THAT WE DO WE DO HAVE A
COMPREHENSIVE AT RELATIVELY
LOW COST MARKETING PLAN THAT
WE HOPE TO -- IMPLEMENT ONCE
THIS BILL IS PASSED AND WE
BELIEVE THAT IT WILL BRING
UP THE A CONTRIBUTIONS TO THE
FUND SUBSTANTIALLY WELL I LOVE
HEARING THIRTY SEVEN THOUSAND
DOLLAR COSTS THAT DOESN'T
SOUND LIKE A REGULAR GOVERNMENT
PROGRAM SO -- GOOD FOR YOU THIS
BONTA WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
THANK YOU SO MUCH MADAM CHAIR
AB TWENTY EIGHT EIGHTY WILL
CONTINUE TO BENEFIT COLLEGE
STUDENTS AND TAXPAYERS BY
EXTENDING THE COLLEGE ACCESS TAX
TAX CREDIT THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT THIS BILL
AND I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST THAT
THIS BILL BE SET FOR A VOTE AND
REFER TO THE HIGHER EDUCATION
COMMITTEE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU I
HAVE -- ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CHOI I I DON'T SEE
-- ASSEMBLY MEMBER BRIAN HERE
ALL RIGHT SO WE ARE ON
ITEM FOUR GOOD AFTERNOON
AND THAT IS A AB EIGHTEEN
NINETY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CHOI WHENEVER YOU'RE READY
THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON
NOT MADAM CHAIR AND THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS I AM
PLEASED TO PRESENT THE
ASSEMBLY B. L. EIGHTEEN NINETY
AB EIGHTY NINE IT IS A
CRUCIAL MEASURE THAT SUPPORT
ALL OF OUR BUSINESSES OF
THE ROCK CALIFORNIA WHO ARE
STRUGGLING TO RECOVER FROM
CALL OF IT NINETEEN AND THEN IT
THIS BAILOUT WOULD CREATE AN
INCOME TAX CREDIT FOR BUSINESS
OWNERS SO WHO WERE MANDATED BY
SENATE BILL ONE FOURTEEN
OUT TO PAY OFF THE NINETEEN THE
SUPPLEMENTAL OF PAID THE
SICK LEAVE I RECOGNIZE
THAT THE BUSINESSES -- HAVE
RECEIVED A FEDERAL ASSISTANCE
UP LIKE THE CARERS
ACT DURING THE HEIGHT OF
THE UP AND THAT MAKE IT AND THAT
THE IOWA STATE IS ESTABLISHED
THAT THE SMALLER BUSINESS
OF COFFEE AT THE NINETEEN RELIEF
FOR GRANTED PROGRAM LAST YEAR
BUT THE WHAT ARE WE DOING THIS
YEAR CALIFORNIA HAS
MOVED UP FROM UP AND THEN MAKE
A STATE DOCTOR ONE ENDEMIC STATE
YET THE HERE WE ARE AGAIN
IMPOSING ON UNFUNDED THE MANDATE
OR NO MORE MOST OF ONE OR MORE
BUSINESSES MY BILL
BUILDS UPON SB OUT ONE FOURTEEN
BY PROVIDING FUNDS FOR
EMPLOYERS -- -- PAYING THEIR
EMPLOYEES SELL COFFEE NINETEEN
SUPPLEMENTAL PAID THE SICK
LEAVE WITH ME TODAY
IS OUR ALL OF TODAY ARE
AMONG WE'RE AT THE -- GLADSTEIN
REPRESENTING AND THE --
CALIFORNIA RETAILERS ASSOCIATION
AND THE PRESTON YOUNG WITH THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
OF TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT OF AB
EIGHTEEN NINE AND THANK YOU
ALSO FOR BEING HERE TODAY
THANK YOU SO EVER THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS PRESTON YOUNG FROM THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
HERE TODAY IN SUPPORT OF
AB EIGHTEEN NINETY AS YOU
KNOW BUSINESSES OF ALL SIZES
HAVE STRUGGLED TREMENDOUSLY
THROUGHOUT THE COURSE OF THIS
PANDEMIC AND THAT'S BEEN DUE TO
A NUMBER OF ISSUES -- GOVERNMENT
IMPOSED LOCKDOWNS CUSTOMER
CAPACITY LIMITATIONS EXPENSIVE
REGULATORY BURDENS AND TAX AND
FEE OBLIGATIONS CONTRIBUTED TO
THE STRUGGLES NOW THE BUSINESSES
THAT DID SURVIVE CONTINUE TO
FACE CHALLENGES NOT THE LEAST
OF WHICH INCLUDE GOVERNMENT
IMPOSE MANDATES FOUND IN SB
ONE FOURTEEN AS YOU KNOW SB
ONE FOURTEEN WAS SIGNED INTO
LAW THIS YEAR PROVIDES UP TO
EIGHTY HOURS PER EMPLOYEE OF
COVERT NINETEEN SUPPLEMENTAL
PAID SICK LEAVE CALCHAMBER
RECOGNIZE THE IMPORTANCE OF
SB ONE FOURTEEN WHILE WE DO
NOT OPPOSE THE BILL REMAINED
EXTREMELY COGNISANT OF THE
MANDATED -- PAID SICK LEAVE AND
THAT WOULD BE ANOTHER GOVERNMENT
IMPOSED MANDATE AND EXPENSE
BORNE BY CALIFORNIA'S EMPLOYERS
HOWEVER AB EIGHTEEN NINETY IS
A COMMON SENSE APPROACH THAT
CAN ACCOMMODATE THE NEW MANDATE
SINCE CALIFORNIA BELIEVES GOOD
POLICY TO PROVIDE EXTENDED SICK
LEAVE FOR COVERT NINETEEN INTO
THE COMING YEAR IN CALIFORNIA
SHOULD USE IT SURPLUS TO HELP
PAY FOR THE ADDED NEW EXPENSE
WHEN THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
MANDATED COVE NINETEEN SICK
LEAVE THEY UNDERSTOOD IT WAS A
DIFFICULT EXPENSE FOR EMPLOYERS
AND OFFERED A CORRESPONDING
TAX CREDIT TO COVER THOSE
COSTS CALCHAMBER PULLED NINE
HUNDRED OF ITS MEMBERS MORE
THAN FIVE HUNDRED PREVIOUSLY
SOUGHT FEDERAL TAX CREDITS
TO OFFSET THE COSTS OF COVE
IN NINETEEN SICK LEAVE THIS
FEDERAL CREDITS HAVE NOW EXPIRED
FORTY PERCENT OF THOSE POLLED
BUSINESSES ARE CONCERNED ABOUT
BEING ABLE TO AFFORD ADDITIONAL
COVERT NINETEEN PAID SICK
LEAVE CALIFORNIA TO ONCE IN A
GENERATION SEVENTY SIX BILLION
DOLLARS SURPLUS LAST YEAR
THIS YOUR CALIFORNIA'S FACING
YET ANOTHER HISTORIC SURPLUS
CALIFORNIA'S RESPONSE TO COVERT
NINETEEN CANNOT CONTINUE TO BE
BORNE BY THE BUSINESS COMMUNITY
AND AB EIGHTEEN NINETY IS A
CHANCE TO OFFER ASSISTANCE
TO COVER EXPENSE BUSINESSES
BEEN MANDATED TO INDOOR SO FOR
THOSE REASONS WE'RE HERE TODAY
IN SUPPORT OF EIGHTEEN NINETY
AND I APPRECIATE THE TIME
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS LIKE TO TAKE THE
AUTHOR FOR BRINGING THIS
BILL FORWARD MARGARET LASTING
HERE ABOUT HALF A CALIFORNIA
RETAILERS ASSOCIATION WERE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
RETAILERS LIKE MANY BUSINESSES
AT PARTICULARLY CONSUMER FACING
BUSINESSES WERE HIT PARTICULARLY
HARD BY THAT PANDEMIC WE
HAD INCONSISTENT DEVASTATING AND
EVER CHANGING RULES THAT WE HAD
TO FACE WHILE TRYING TO SERVE
OUR CUSTOMERS AS BEST WE COULD
-- THE LEGISLATURE HAS SEEN FIT
APPROPRIATELY TO OFFER OTHER
TYPES OF BUSINESSES TAX RELIEF
DURING THIS CHALLENGING TIME
IN THE RETAILER'S SUPPORT THIS
BILL BECAUSE WE TO BELIEVE THIS
IS APPROPRIATE TAX POLICY GIVEN
THE CURRENT IMPACTS OF SB ONE
FOURTEEN AND OTHER CHALLENGES WE
FACE SO WE ENCOURAGE THE SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL AND AGAIN THANK
THE AUTHOR AND THE COMMITTEE
FOR THEIR CONSIDERATION THANK
YOU -- ARE THERE ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES IN THE ROOM
WISHING TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM TURN
MEMBERS KATIE HANSON WITH
THE CALIFORNIA RESTAURANT
ASSOCIATION WE'RE HERE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB EIGHTEEN
NINETY AND THANK YOU TO THE
AUTHOR FOR IT INTRODUCING
THIS IMPORTANT BILL THANK YOU
AND CAN I HAVE A MODERATOR
PLEASE OPEN UP THE LINE
FOR SUPPORTING TESTIMONY
RIGHT TO SUPPORT AB ONE
EIGHT NINE ZERO PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO ON YOUR PHONE
AND WE DO HAVE BONTA
PHONE LINE NUMBER SEVEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD THE LINE IS OPEN
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS DATE OR JUST ON
BEHALF OF THE FAMILY BUSINESS
ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT
RIGHT NOW GO TO THE LINE NUMBER
EIGHTEEN AGAIN PLEASE GO AHEAD
CANALI EIGHTEEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN BMO CAPITAL PLEASE
CHECK IT CORPORATE FINANCE AT
GREAT
LAGAGA LINE NUMBER
TWENTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD YOUR LINE IS OPEN
THE MOMENT
AGAIN LINE OF THE
TWENTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD YOUR LINE IS OPEN
BAND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
BRIAN LITTLE CALIFORNIA
FARM BUREAU FEDERATION
ALSO SUPPORT THANK YOU
I'LL GO THROUGH LINE
NUMBER TWENTY FIVE PLEASE
GO AHEAD THE LINE IS OPEN
AFTERNOON CAN YOU SHARE MEMBERS
THIS IS SABRINA LOCKHART CALLING
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
TRACTION PARKS ASSOCIATION
MANY OF OUR PARKS ARE CLOSED
FOR MORE THAN A YEAR SO WE
ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB
EIGHTEEN NINETY THANK YOU
I'M NOT GONNA LINE NUMBER SIXTY
ONE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD --
GOOD AFTERNOON MATTHEW ALLEN
WITH WESTERN GROWERS ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
ONE MORE MOMENT WE'LL GO TO LINE
NUMBER TEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
BECAUSE IT TEARS THEM YET THAT
NEEDS A FARMER'S LEGALLY EXPORT
NO MORE QUESTIONS ARE NO MORE
COMMITTEE APOLOGY PLEASE GO
AHEAD RIGHT THANK YOU IS THERE
ANYBODY IN THE ROOM THAT WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
THE MODERATOR PLEASE
OPEN THE MAIN LINE FOR
ANY OPPOSITION TESTIMONY
LADIES AND GENTLEMAN STICKING
UP A DIFFERENT THIS RESPONDENT
ZERO ON YOUR TELEPHONE KEYPAD
WE HAVE NO LAND THANK YOU
AT THIS TIME ALL RIGHT
DO WE HAVE -- COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CLARK SO IF
THERE'S SEVERAL PROBLEMS I
SEE WITH THE BELL UP NUMBER
ONE AS WELL -- CERTAINLY ARE
CAUGHT WELL YOU KNOW WE'VE ALL
SEEN RESTAURANTS JUST DISAPPEAR
THEY'RE NOT HERE ANYMORE ARM
AND THAT HAPPENED I THINK
REGARDLESS OF WHETHER OR
NOT THERE WAS GOING TO BE
ANOTHER TWO WEEKS OF SICK
PAY UP BUT ALSO WE HAVE MANY
COMPANIES WHO DID VERY WELL
-- AMAZON --
ASSUME AND FURTHER THEY
ALREADY HAVE POLICIES THAT
WOULD ALLOW FOR TWO WEEKS OF
SICK LEAVE -- ARE WE GOING TO
GIVE THEM A TAX BREAK AS WELL
THEY SHOULD BE ALL ALL OUT
UNIFORMED UP BECAUSE -- --
SMALL WATER LARGER I DON'T
KNOW SOME OF THEM HAVE --
AT THEIR CAPACITY TO PAY
THE TAX ABOUT THE I THINK WITH
THIS OF THE OVERALL WITHOUT
SO MANY A SMALL BUSINESSES
SO THAT HAVE A CELL PHONE THE
FROM THIS UP AND THEN A COUPLE
TWO YEARS AGO AND THE NATIONAL
MANY OF THEM HAVE A CLOVE STYLE
AND THEN MY DEAR THE CONCERN
THAT I HAVE IS THAT HOW TO
BRING THEM BACK HELLO AFTER
THEY HAVING CLOSE TO BUT THE
ONES ARE BARELY HANGING ON I
THINK IT IS -- TAX CREDIT WOULD
BE TREMENDOUS HELP YES BUT YOU
ALSO WANTED TO GO TO COMPANIES
THAT PROSPERED AND ALREADY
HAVE THE POLICY SO WE WEREN'T
REALLY IMPOSING ANYTHING ON
THEM FURTHER THERE WERE OTHER
BUSINESSES THAT GOD -- THE
PPP LOANS TO KEEP THEIR PEOPLE
ON EVEN IF THEY COULDN'T BE
WORKING SO IT'S YOU KNOW YOU'RE
YOU'RE YOUR BILL IS GOING TO
BE VERY EXPENSIVE UNLESS YOU
CAN EXCLUDE THE PEOPLE
WHO HAD THINGS LIKE P. P. P.
-- I DON'T LOAN SPECTER GUESS
FROM THE GOVERNMENT OTHERS
WHO GOT THAT AND THEN ALSO
COMPANIES THAT ALREADY HAD --
-- SICK LEAVE POLICIES SO
WE WEREN'T IMPOSING ANYTHING
ON THEM IF YOU DON'T DO THAT
THE BILL'S GOING TO BECOME
SO EXPENSIVE IT'LL NEVER GET
THROUGH APPROPRIATIONS SO I
THINK YOU NEED TO THINK ABOUT
THAT IN TERMS OF GETTING THE
BILL THROUGH WHICH YOU WANT
TO MORE NARROWLY TARGETED AND
THEN I THINK THE YOU'D HAVE
A BETTER CHANCE THANK YOU
YEAH WELL I'M WILLING TO OUR
TALK OFFERS A ABOUT THE ANY
-- COMPANIES -- THAT HAVE --
-- PROSPERED THE DURING THAT
TIME AND THEN IT BECAUSE OF
THE NATURE OF THE BUSINESSES
-- HOW WE HAVE A MAJORITY
THAT I KNOW HAVE SUFFERED AND
THEN ALSO INITIAL P. P. P.
-- HAVE HELPED THE INITIAL LAW
THE SHOCK WHEN NUMBER SO MANY
BUSINESSES A WERE -- MANDATED TO
CLOSE AS YOU KNOW THE AND THEN
THE CAST ASTON OVER THE STILL
WE IT IS STILL GOING ON OVER
TWO YEARS SELL HAHA LOCKDOWN
AND -- MANY MANY HAVE SUFFERED
THAT IS A THEY ARE BARELY
SURVIVING AND ON ON HERE
ON TOP OF THAT THE BECAUSE
OF THE STATE ONE THAT
NATIONAL POLICY MANDATING
FORCED TO TWO WEEKS OF HEY
MAKE THE PAY MANSARD MY QUESTION
I THINK WE CAN GET ON OTHER
PEOPLE'S QUESTIONS THANK YOU
THANK YOU DO WE HAVE ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS NOW ARE RIGHT
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE MISTER
YEAH THANK YOU ENSURE HEARD
UP FROM THE -- -- SUPPORTER
OF TESTIMONIES SO BECAUSE NO
OPPOSITION OUR FRANCHISE -- TECH
SUPPORT THE HAS OUTLINED THE
A FEW POLICY IMPLEMENTATION OF
CONSIDERATIONS THAT THE AUDIO
TESTING -- JEEZ AMENDMENTS ARE
-- IN NATURE OR TAKEN SECOND
FLOOR I INTRODUCED AB A
TEN NINETY TO HELP US SUPPORT
OUR BUSINESSES AND OUR HOPE
BUT WE CAN CONTINUE WITH HIS --
COMPENSATION FOR ANY OF FOR THE
QUESTIONS SHOW YOU MIGHT HAVE
OUR BUSINESS -- DESERVE A BETTER
THEY DESERVE A LOT MORE
FINANCIAL SUPPORT THE AFTER A
MANDATE THAT THE THE SOLE LITTLE
LAW FOR OUR SMALL PARTICULARLY
SMALL BUSINESS EMPLOYERS FOR
WHETHER IT BE ARE A TAX CREDIT
LEDGER ONE ANOTHER TYPE WELL
ABOVE FUNDING MECHANISM OF BE
OPEN TO WORKING WITH YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND THE OR THE MEMBERS
FOR THESE REASONS I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE
ON A. B. SEVEN --
AB EIGHT IT
THIS BILL IS AB R.
ARM EIGHTEEN NINETY THANK YOU
RIGHT THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE
APPRECIATE -- -- PRESENTATION
AND -- NEXT UP WE HAVE -- FILE
ITEM FIVE AB IN NINETEEN
THIRTY THREE THIS FRIEDMAN
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
OKAY I FIRST OF ALL I WOULD
JUST LIKE TO SAY THAT WITH
REGARD TO THE ANALYSIS WE ARE
FINE WITH A FIVE YEAR SUNSET
ON THE BILL TO COMPLY WITH THE
COMMITTEE'S TAX EXPENDITURE
POLICY AS DISCUSSED IN SECTION
ONE ON PAGE SEVEN AND WE WERE
WORKING WITH THE REALTORS AND
ARE WILLING TO AMEND THE BILL
TO ESTABLISH A PENALTY OF
PERJURY AGAINST ANY DEVELOPER
WHO CLAIMS THE EXEMPTION AND
DOESN'T BUILD UP WITHIN THE
SCOPE OF WHAT THE BILL INTENDS
TO PREVENT POSSIBLE FRAUD I'M
PLEASED TO PRESENT AB -- --
NINETEEN THIRTY THREE WHICH IS
A BILL TO EXPAND THE PROPERTY
TAX WELFARE EXEMPTION TO
ELIGIBLE NONPROFIT CORPORATIONS
THAT SELL AFFORDABLE HOUSING
UNITS TO LOWER MODERATE INCOME
PEOPLE ONE OF THE BIGGEST
COMPLAINTS WE HEAR ABOUT HOUSING
IS THAT WHILE THERE IS SOME
A RENTAL UNITS AVAILABLE FOR
LOW INCOME INDIVIDUALS IT'S
ALMOST IMPOSSIBLE ESPECIALLY
IN THIS HOUSING MARKET FOR
THOSE INDIVIDUALS TO BE ABLE
TO PURCHASE A HOME AND THEY
THEIR BY BUILD EQUITY TO CREATE
STABILITY FOR THEMSELVES AND
THIS BILL -- WE HAVE CREATED
IN CONJUNCTION WITH OF NONPROFIT
DEVELOPERS WHO DO EXACTLY THAT
WHO SEEK TO BUILD OWNERSHIP
AFFORDABLE -- HOUSING THE
CURRENT WELFARE EXEMPTION
ALLOWS NONPROFIT CORPORATIONS
THAT REHABILITATE OR CONSTRUCT
HOUSING FOR SALE TO LOW INCOME
FAMILIES -- THAT REQUIRES
THAT THE HOUSING BE FINANCE
WITH ZERO INTEREST RATE LOAN
THIS IS THE EXEMPTION COMMONLY
USED BY HABITAT FOR HUMANITY
FOR EXAMPLE HOWEVER NONPROFIT
DEVELOPERS THAT BUILD DEED
RESTRICTED AFFORDABLE HOUSING
FOR HOME BUYERS HAVE BEEN
DENIED A PROPERTY TAX EXEMPTION
BECAUSE THE HOME BUYER IS PAYING
INTEREST ON A CONVENTIONAL
MORTGAGE AND SET OF FINANCING
THROUGH A ZERO PERCENT INTEREST
LOAN AND I'VE HEARD FROM ONE
NONPROFIT DEVELOPER HERITAGE
HOUSING PARTNERS THAT IT'S
FORCED TO PAY PROPERTY TAXES
FROM THE TIME THEY PURCHASED
THE LAND THROUGH CONSTRUCTION
UNTIL THE CLOSE OF ESCROW WHEN
THEY TURN THE KEYS OVER TO THE
BUYER THIS RESULT IN PROPERTY
TAX PAYMENTS OF MANY THOUSANDS
OF DOLLARS PER HOME THAT COULD
INSTEAD BE PLACED BACK INTO
DEVELOPMENT AND CONSTRUCTION
TO ALLOW MORE IF THIS TYPE
OF HOUSING TO BE PROVIDED AB
NINETEEN THIRTY THREE PROVIDES
HERITAGE AND OTHER FUTURE
NONPROFIT A PROPERTY TAX WELFARE
EXEMPTION JUST ON THE PROPERTY
TAXES PAID FROM WHEN THE LAND
WAS PURCHASED UNTIL THE HOME
IS TURNED OVER TO THE BUYERS
FROM THERE THE BUYER WILL BEGIN
TO PAY PROPERTY TAXES OVER
DECADES LONG A DEED RESTRICTED
MORGUE OVER THE DECADES LONG
THE DEED RESTRICTED MORTGAGE
THIS EXEMPTION WILL EASILY PAY
FOR ITSELF THROUGH NEW HOUSING
STOCK AND STABLE HOMEOWNERSHIP
THEY WILL ALSO RESULT IN SAVINGS
ALLOWING HERITAGE AND OTHER
SIMILAR NONPROFITS TO CONSTRUCT
EVEN MORE DEVELOPMENTS AND WE
KNOW THIS BECAUSE THEY TOLD
US THAT THIS WILL UNLOCK THEIR
ABILITY TO BUILD MORE NONPROFIT
MORE AFFORDABLE FOR A FOR SALE
-- HOUSES AB NINETEEN
THIRTY THREE IS SUPPORTED BY
THE ASSESSOR OF L. A. COUNTY
JEFFREY PRANG AND THE CALIFORNIA
CATHOLIC CONFERENCE TESTIFYING
IN SUPPORT TODAY OR DAVID WILL
FOR HERITAGE HOUSING PARTNERS
AND HOLLY FROM ANTI D. HAYES
IS FOR HABITAT FOR HUMANITY
INSTEAD OF BUYING NONPROFITS
TO BUILD SINGLE FAMILY HOMES
AND ENCOURAGE HOMEOWNERSHIP
WILL LEAD TO MORE DESPERATELY
NEED TO HELP LEAD TO THE
HOUSING AND THE COST OF THIS IS
INFINITESIMALLY SMALL BECAUSE
THERE'S JUST NOT A TON OF THIS
HOUSING BUILT I LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THE COMMITTEE AS HE
CONSIDERS THIS BILL AND I WOULD
REQUEST YOUR FULL CONSIDERATION
THANK YOU THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FRIEDMAN -- A WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT ABSOLUTELY YES
IN SUPPORT MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS GOOD AFTERNOON -- DAVID
WOLF WITH LOVERS CONSULTING
TODAY'S THE AUTHOR MENTIONED
REPRESENTING HERITAGE HOUSING
PARTNERS WHERE THE SPONSOR
OF AB NINETEEN THIRTY THREE
-- THE AUTHOR MEMBERS DID A
EXCELLENT JOB SUMMARIZING THE
BILL SO I'M JUST GONNA MAKE SOME
BRIEF COMMENTS AND OF COURSE
MENTIONED THAT I'M HERE TO
ANSWER ANY TECHNICAL QUESTIONS
-- THE COMMITTEE MIGHT HAVE
-- FUNDS FOR OWNER OCCUPIED
DEVELOPMENT PROGRAMS ACROSS
ALL INCOME LEVELS ARE REALLY
NEEDED IT'S HOUSING PARTNERS
IS REALLY THE ONLY NONPROFIT
IN THIS SPACE THAT WE'VE BEEN
ABLE TO FIND IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THE WELFARE EXEMPTION
PIECE FOR MODERATE INCOME ALSO
MEMBERS WHICH IS IN THE BILL
IS SORELY NEEDED THE U. S.
CENSUS DATA ON RENTAL INCOMES
FOR L. A. COUNTY AND THE SF BAY
AREA SHOWS JUST THE NEED FOR
THIS AND I COUNTY TWENTY ONE
PERCENT OF RENTER HOUSEHOLDS
MAKE A HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS
OR MORE IN THE SAN FRANCISCO
BAY AREA TWENTY SIX PERCENT
OF RENTER HOUSEHOLDS MAKE OVER
A HUNDRED AND FIFTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS FOR A YEAR OR HIGHER
-- I THINK THE POINT NEEDS TO
BE MADE THAT EVERY WRITER WHO
BECOMES A FIRST TIME HOMEBUYER
FREES UP A UNIT OF RENTAL
HOUSING WHICH DOES IN TURN HELP
TO ALLEVIATE THE HOUSING CRISIS
THE AUTHOR MENTIONED THAT THE L.
A. COUNTY ASSESSOR -- SUPPORTS
THE BILL HERITAGE IS BUILT A
HUNDRED PERCENT OF THE UNITS TO
THIS POINT IN L. A. COUNTY AND
THEY SUPPORT THE BILL BECAUSE
HERITAGE HAS A TWENTY YEAR TRACK
RECORD OF DEVELOPING AFFORDABLE
HOUSING FOR FIRST TIME HOME
BUYERS WITHIN THEIR TWENTY YEAR
HISTORY HERITAGE HAS ALWAYS
ONE HUNDRED PERCENT OF THE TIME
BOUGHT BACK THEIR HOUSING UNITS
AFTER THE ORIGINAL FAMILY IS
MOVED OUT IN ORDER TO PROVIDE
SUPPORT FOR ANOTHER LOW INCOME
FIRST TIME HOME BUYING FAMILY
AND IN CLOSING MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS THIS EXEMPTION DOES NOT
TAKE FUNDING AWAY FROM ANY STATE
PROGRAM -- BECAUSE HERITAGE
HAS BEEN AROUND FOR SO LONG
WE HAVE DATA FROM THEIR OWN
DEVELOPMENTS SHOWING THAT WHILE
THEY WOULD BE AN UP FRONT COST
TO COUNTIES EXEMPTION DOES
PAY FOR ITSELF TO THE PROPERTY
TAXES THAT THE HOMEOWNER PAYS
AGAIN AS THE AUTHOR INDICATED
-- SO WITH THAT I WOULD
ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT OF THE
PROPERTY THANK YOU AND WE ARE
TAKING A BREAK -- AND GOING
TO DO ROLL CALL REALLY QUICK
ESTABLISH A QUORUM IRWIN
HERE WHEN GRAY
GRAYSON HERE
LEVINE PLEASE
MAYES THAT'S ONE
OH GOD MULLIN
HERE PETRIE-NORRIS
QUIRK YEAH RIVAS SEYARTO
WE'VE GOT A CORE OKAY SO
I I TRULY APOLOGIZE FOR THAT
THAT'S A LOT OF COMMITTEE
MEETINGS GOING ON MADAM CHAIRMAN
SORRY FOR MISSING THE QUEUE I
WAS LIKE OH NO NO WAIT WHAT WE
HAVE A QUORUM SO -- I WILL ASK
THE SECOND WITNESS TO GO AHEAD
WITH YOUR PRESENTATION THANK YOU
HI FOR ME THEY HAS SIX HERE ON
BEHALF A HABITAT FOR HUMANITY
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME TODAY AND I JUST WANT TO
REMIND THE COMMITTEE THE MEDIAN
HOME PRICES IN CALIFORNIA
ARE NOW REACHING THIS YEAR
OVER EIGHT HUNDRED AND THIRTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS THE MEDIAN HOME
PRICE THANK GOODNESS I AM NOT
TRYING TO ENTER THE MARKET AS
A FIRST TIME HOME BUYER NOW IN
TWENTY TWENTY TWO ABOUT HABITAT
FOR HUMANITY CONTINUES TO TRY TO
BUILD DEVELOP AND FINANCE AND
REMIND THE COMMITTEE WERE ALSO
UNDERWRITERS AND FINANCERS OF
THESE MORTGAGES THAT TO BRING
OUR FAMILIES INTO THE HOMES AND
JUST IN SANDERS AND SAN MATTEO
COUNTY ALONE WE RECENTLY HAD
A TWENTY SIX UNIT PROJECT WITH
OVER ONE THOUSAND APPLICATIONS
TO THAT JUST TWENTY SIX UNITS
IN SAN MATEO COUNTY AND BOTH
REDWOOD CITY AND DALY CITY AND
ANOTHER EIGHTY UNIT PROJECT IN
MARIN COUNTY WAS JUST RECENTLY
APPROVED BY THE CITY COUNCIL
NEVADA JUST A COUPLE OF WEEKS
AGO WE ALREADY HAVE FOUR HUNDRED
INQUIRIES OF APPLICANTS TO GET
INTO THOSE HOMES SO CLEARLY
THERE IS NOT ENOUGH -- HOUSE
AND HOUSES ON THE MARKET THAT
THESE FAMILIES THAT ARE EIGHTY
PERCENT OF THE LOWER THEIR
DEMAND INCOME THAT HAVE A DESIRE
AND A DREAM OF OWNING A HOME
BUT IT'S JUST THEIR INCOME LEVEL
THAT IS PROHIBITING THEM FROM
BUYING A HOME BECAUSE I DOUBLE
CHECKED THAT FIVE I'M TO ONE
RATIO OF QUALIFIED APPLICANTS
OF OF THOSE APPLICANTS IT'S FIVE
TO ONE TO QUALIFY TO BUY A HOME
WE JUST CAN'T BILL THEM AND GET
ENOUGH OF THEM FAST ENOUGH AND
HAVE IT HAS TO CONTINUE JUST
LIKE HERITAGE HOME TO TRY TO
FINANCE THE GAP BETWEEN WHAT
THAT FAMILY CAN AFFORD IN THE
MORTGAGE THAT WE'RE SPEAKING OF
AND THE GAP TO ACTUALLY BUILD
THE HOMES OF THIS PROPERTY TAX
RELIEF HELPS BRING DOWN THE
KIND OF THE COST OF CONSTRUCTION
OVERALL AND JUST LIKE THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SAID IT REALLY
DOES GO BACK INTO HABITAT FOR
HUMANITY TO HELP US BUILD MORE
HOMES FOR OTHER FAMILIES SO
WE'VE HAD A INVOLVED WITH THE
TIME HABITAT MANY OF YOU'RE
FAMILIAR WITH THE OLD MODEL AND
IN SOME COUNTIES ARE STILL SING
ONE FAMILY ONE HOUSE AT A TIME
BUT LIKE YOU JUST HEARD WERE
EVOLVING WITH THE TIMES AND
HABITAT CAN'T UNDERWRITE EIGHTY
UNITS A YEAR SO THEY ARE HAVING
A PARTNER WITH SOME CONVENTIONAL
LENDERS TO HELP UNDERWRITE THE
LOANS THAT WE CAN BUILD MORE
MORE HOMES OVER SO IN ORDER
TO EVOLVE WITH THE TIMES WE
NEED THAT STATUTE RELATED TO
PROPERTY TAX EXEMPTIONS TO ALSO
EVOLVE WITH THE TIMES AND ALLOW
FOR THIS CREATIVE FLEXIBILITY
TO PARTNER WITH MIXED INCOME
DEVELOPERS AS WELL AS MARKET
CONVENTIONAL -- LENDERS TO
HELP US SERVE MORE FAMILIES TO
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR I THOUGHT
RIGHT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
OF IT DO WE HAS ANYBODY
IN THE ROOM THAT WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
THE MODERATOR IS ARE THERE
ANYBODY IS THERE ANYBODY
ON THE LINE THAT WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN THIS BIG
DIPPER PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO ON YOUR TELEPHONE KEYPAD
BUT OUR FIRST LINE NUMBER
TWENTY THREE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD
YOU CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
CHAVEZ WHAT THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF REALTORS HERE
AT THE CLEANER WE WOULD LIKE
TO ACKNOWLEDGE THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER AND SPONSOR FOR ENGAGING
ABOUT FOR DIALOGUE WITH DR
AS IT RELATES TO OUR CONCERN
WE LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING
OUR DISCUSSION WITH THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER AND SPONSOR
THEN ONCE AGAIN BUT JUST LIKE
TO THANK THEM FOR ENGAGING
WITH THE ARCH IN ORDER TO
ADDRESS OUR CONCERNS THANK YOU
WE HAVE AN ADDITIONAL
AND AT THIS TIME
AS ALL RIGHT
NOBODY ELSE
SIR ANYBODY IN THE
ROOM THAT WOULD LIKE
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
ANYBODY IN THE SOMEBODY
HAS SOMETHING TO SAY
IS THERE ANYBODY ON THE
LINE THAT WOULD LIKE
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
GENERALLY SPEAKING
OPPOSITION PLEASE TERRACE
LONDON ZERO AT THIS TIME
WE HAVE NO RIGHT TO QUEUE AT
THIS TIME ALL RIGHT DO WE HAVE
ANY QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GRAYSON THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR THAT NOT SO
MUCH A QUESTION JUST A COMMENT
-- ONE OF REALLY CHAU PRECIADO
XIN TO THE AUTHOR FOR THE BILL
AND OUT OF BOX THINKING ANYTHING
THAT WE CAN DO IN THE STATE
RIGHT NOW TO HELP AND HOUSING
ESPECIALLY WHEN IT COMES TO
AFFORDABLE HOUSING -- PARTNERS
THAT WE HAVE AND TRYING TO
REDUCE THE COST WOULD HELP
PEOPLE GET INTO HOMEOWNERSHIP
AND THIS IS ONE OF THOSE
INNOVATIVE INKING IDEAS
AND -- THE AUTHORS WORK I KNOW
IN -- HER DISTRICT AND ALSO
WITH THE HOUSING WORKING
GROUP HAS BEEN EXTRAORDINARY
SO THANK YOU FOR THIS
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
OKAY I DID -- BUT I GUESS
MAYBE FOR THE SPONSORS --
YOU KNOW OBVIOUSLY HOUSING
IS A HUGE ISSUE BUT WHEN
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT THE --
WE'RE EXPANDING NOW THE --
WELFARE EXEMPTION TO COVER
PROPERTY THAT'S BEING SOLD TO
MODERATE INCOME HOMEOWNERS
AND -- DO YOU THINK THIS
MIGHT CREATE A PRECEDENT THAT
WE WOULD BE SUBSIDIZING MODERATE
INCOME HOUSING THROUGH THE TAX
CODE AS OPPOSED TO -- FOCUSING
ONLY ON TRULY AFFORDABLE HOUSING
THE PRESIDENT IS KIND OF
THE CONCERN WE HAVE IN THIS
COMMITTEE I WOULD THERE IS
SOME PRECEDENT -- THAT AGENCIES
FORMALLY KNOWN AS REDEVELOPMENT
AGENCIES USED TO HAVE A BUDGET
THAT WAS SET ASIDE FOR LOW
AND MODERATE INCOME HOMES AND
THOSE WERE DUE TO RESTRICTED
AND HELP SUBSIDIZE AND SOME OF
THOSE PROJECTS CONTINUE TO --
EXIST AND CONTINUE TO ALLOW FOR
MODERATE INCOME -- THE INTENSE
TO LIVE IN THOSE HOMES ALSO I
BELIEVE JUST LAST YEAR IN THE
STATE BUDGET THERE WAS KELLY
TO PAY WITH A NEW PROGRAM FOR
MIXED INCOME THAT INCLUDED
MODERATE INCOME THAT HAS A
TAX CREDIT PROGRAM IS JUST
FOR RENTAL -- SO HOMEOWNERSHIP
DOESN'T HAVE SUCH EVEN AT LEAST
THERE'S TWO PROGRAMS I'M AWARE
OF THAT EVENT FOR RENTAL BUT
AGAIN NONE FOR HOMEOWNERSHIP
-- SINCE REDEVELOPMENT AGENCIES
AND AND -- AND WENT AWAY
THERE HASN'T BEEN ANY FROM BUT
SPECIFICALLY FOR PRODUCTION
OF -- HOMEOWNERSHIP AND
AT I MEAN THERE IS A PRETTY
SIGNIFICANT DIFFERENCE IN THE
-- SALARY REQUIREMENTS FROM
BEGINS WITH HER LOOKING AT LOW
INCOME FOR A FOUR PERSON
HOUSEHOLD AS OPPOSED TO MODERATE
INCOME I MEAN YOU'RE WHAT WE
WOULD BE WITH THE TAX CODE
SUBSIDIZING PEOPLE THAT MIGHT
BE MAKING YOU KNOW DEPENDING
ON THE AREA THAT YOU'RE IN
-- WELL OVER A HUNDRED FIFTY
THOUSAND IS IS THAT CORRECT
MADAM YEAH MAN I'M SURE I MEAN
IT DEPENDS ON WHAT COUNTY WERE
TALKING ABOUT OBVIOUSLY WHAT
THE ERROR IN THE AREA MEDIAN
INCOME IS YOU KNOW OF OF
THAT COUNTY YOU KNOW THAT AREA
BUT AGAIN JUST WOULD LIKE TO
STRESS THE COMMENTS THAT I MADE
DURING MY EARLIER TESTIMONY IN
THAT IN THE SAN FRANCISCO BAY
AREA FOR INSTANCE TWENTY SIX
PERCENT OF CURRENT RENTERS HAVE
AN INCOME OF OVER A HUNDRED
AND FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS A
YEAR AND THERE IS THERE'S NO
HOUSING STOCK FOR THEM TO MOVE
INTO SECUELA THINK THERE'S AN
ARGUMENT TO BE MADE FOR MODERATE
INCOME AT IT BUT THE QUESTION IS
DOES IT WITH THIS THIS --
WELFARE EXEMPTION ISN'T REALLY
DESIGNATED FOR LOWER INCOME
-- -- PEOPLE THAT WE ARE
TRYING TO FIND HOUSING FOR
SALE HISTORICALLY MEN I'M
SURE THAT'S TRUE I MEAN THAT
CAN I DECIDE -- IT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING AND I I NEED TO
LOOK MORE INTO THIS BUT IT'S
MY UNDERSTANDING THAT THAT SAME
TAX CREDIT THOUGH IS USED FOR
MODERATE INCOME RENTAL PROPERTY
SO IT'S ALREADY BEING USED FOR
THAT PURPOSE THIS WOULD JUST
EXTEND IT FOR THAT THE -- FOR
SALE PROPERTY AN ADDITION THE
NUMBERS REALLY HAVEN'T KEPT UP
WITH WHAT'S HAPPENING IN THE
HOUSING MARKET SO IF THE INTENT
REALLY IS TO MAKE SURE THAT
PEOPLE WHO ARE WORKING PEOPLE
CAN AFFORD TO LIVE SOMEWHERE --
IT STILL SERVES THE SAME PURPOSE
-- THAT WAS INTENDED FOR --
AND -- AND BECAUSE THIS IS
REALLY ONLY THE TAX RELIEF
DURING THE PERIOD FROM THE
PURCHASE OF THE PROPERTY THROUGH
CONSTRUCTION IT'S NOT INPUT TO
THE ONES THAT WITHOUT PROPERTIES
PURCHASED IT'S NO LONGER IT THEN
THEY START PAYING TAXES ON IT SO
IT'S REALLY A VERY SMALL AMOUNT
OF TIME TO HELP THOSE DEVELOPERS
GET THE PROJECTS ON THE GROUND
I DO WANNA REMIND THE COMMITTEE
THAT THE HOMEOWNERS REGARDLESS
OF THEIR INCOME LEVEL DO YOU
HAVE TO PAY PROPERTY TAXES IT'S
REASSESSED AT THE POINT THAT
THEY TAKE OVER THAT THEY GET
A PROPERTY TAX BILL I'D LIKE
RENTAL UNITS WILL REMAIN EXEMPT
FOR THE LIFE OF THE PROPERTY
I I -- DEFINITELY APPRECIATE
ALL THOSE ARGUMENTS AND --
WE WILL BE WORKING WITH WITH
YOU ON ON THE BILL ITSELF
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION REALLY APPRECIATE
YOUR HELP WITH THE BILL
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT THANK
YOU MISTRESS APPS ALL RIGHTS
THIS RUBIO I BELIEVE YOU ARE
YES ITEM NUMBER
SIX AB TWENTY SIXTY FIVE
WHENEVER YOU ARE READY
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT AB TWENTY SIXTY FIVE
AN IMPORTANT MEASURE THAT WOULD
PROVIDE MUCH NEEDED RELIEF TO
CALIFORNIA BUSINESSES WE'RE
ALL TOO FAMILIAR WITH THE
DIFFICULT DECISIONS YOU HAVE TO
BE MADE AT THE ONSET OF COVER
NINETEEN PANDEMIC IN TWENTY
TWENTY FACED WITH AN UNCERTAIN
BUDGET OUTLOOK AND THEN EVEN
LESS CERTAIN ECONOMIC FUTURE
SEVERAL LEGISLATIVE CHANGES
WERE MADE TO STABILIZE AND
PREPARE THE STATE FOR WHAT
WAS A POTENTIALLY DEVASTATING
REVENUE HIT TO OUR PROGRAMS
AMONG THE MANY STEPS TAKEN WITH
THE SUSPENSION OF NET OPERATING
LOSSES OR AND -- AL'S WHICH
PRESERVE BILLIONS OF DOLLARS
FOR THE STATE TO SAFEGUARD OUR
ESSENTIAL PROGRAMS AND ALSO
PROVIDE A VALUABLE TOOL FOR
CALIFORNIA BUSINESSES TO RECOUP
CAPITAL WHEN FUTURE OPERATIONS
BECOME PROFITABLE AND ALLOW LONG
TERM BOLD INVESTMENTS TO EXPAND
BUSINESS S. AS IN CALIFORNIA
FORTUNATELY FOR THE STATE OUR
ECONOMIC THERE ARE ECONOMY
PROVED FAR MORE RESILIENT THAN
EXPECTED AND REVENUE REMAINS
STRONG UNFORTUNATELY THE US
THAT SUSPENSION OF AN ALLS
LEVIED A BLOW TO MANY CALIFORNIA
COMPANIES THAT WERE LEFT
WITHOUT THE CRITICAL FINANCIAL
FLEXIBILITY FLEXIBILITY AND ALL
WOULD HAVE PROVIDED THEM WHILE
THE GOVERNOR HAS SIGNED SB ONE
THIRTEEN WHICH ENDS THE NO ALSO
SUSPENSION FOR TWENTY TWENTY TWO
CALIFORNIA COMPANIES IMPACTED
BY AND ALL SUSPENSION IN TWENTY
TWENTY AND TWENTY ONE ARE STILL
LEFT WITHOUT ANY RELIEF AB
TWENTY SIXTY FIVE WOULD PROVIDE
THAT RELIEF TO SOME OF THE MOST
SIGNIFICANT IMPACT THE COMPANIES
SIMPLY PUT THIS BILL WOULD
GIVE RECORDS FOR COMPANIES THAT
HAD SIGNIFICANT REVENUE EVENTS
ALLOWING A ONE TIME KERRY BACK
FOR THAT YEARS I KNOW AL WAS
SUSPENDED WELL THIS BILL WILL
NOT COVER EVERY ENTITY THAT
WAS IMPACTED BY THE SUSPENSION
OF THE AND I'LL CREDIT IT WILL
PROVIDE AN AVENUE FOR THOSE
WITH THE MOST SIGNIFICANT
LOSSES AT AND DEMONSTRATE THAT
THE STATE IS HERE TO SUPPORT
THE COMPANY'S INVESTED RIGHT
HERE IN CALIFORNIA WITHOUT HERE
WITH ME TODAY TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT IS TIME SHE AND GREG
TURNER ON BEHALF OF CARDINAL
ENERGY THANK YOU THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR MISTER TURNER'S
BEEN KIND ENOUGH TO YIELD ONE
MINUTE OF THIS TIME SO IF I GO
SLIGHTLY OVER FOR KEEPING TRACK
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
REVENUE AND TAXATION COMMITTEE
I AM TOM SHE AND I'M HERE TODAY
ON BEHALF OF MY CLIENT CARRILLO
ENERGY AND I WANT TO THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY
THIS AFTERNOON WE ESPECIALLY
WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
HER LEADERSHIP IN THIS AREA
OF TAX FAIRNESS AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT A NET OPERATING LOSS
OR AS WE SAY AND -- WELL OCCURS
WHEN THE BUSINESSES EXPENSES
EXCEEDS ITS TAXABLE INCOME IN A
GIVEN PERIOD AND THEY CAN THEN
BE CARRIED FORWARD TO OFFSET
FUTURE TAXABLE INCOME IN ORDER
TO REDUCE FUTURE TAX LIABILITY
NO WELLS HELP SMOOTH OUT THE
INCOME AND TAXES PAID OVER A
BUSINESS CYCLE AND THIS ALLOWS
BUSINESSES TO MAKE EFFICIENT
DECISIONS REGARDING FINANCING
AND THEIR INVESTMENTS THIS
TAX POLICY IS PARTICULARLY
IMPORTANT WHEN IT COMES TO
BUSINESS INVESTMENTS AND
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT A COMPANY
MAY BE MORE WILLING TO MAKE
INVESTMENTS IN MACHINERY AND
PEOPLE KNOWING THAT THEY'RE
GOING TO LOSE MONEY ON THE FRONT
END WITH THE UNDERSTANDING THAT
THEY CAN CARRY THOSE LOSSES
FORWARD AND ON THE BACK AND
RECOUP SOME OF THAT CAPITAL
THANK YOUS THOSE INVESTMENTS
COMPANIES THAT OPERATE HERE IN
CALIFORNIA AND ELSEWHERE THE
ABSOLUTELY NEED TO KNOW WHAT
THE TAX RULES ARE GOING TO
BE WHEN THEY'RE MAKING THOSE
TYPES OF MULTI YEAR INVESTMENT
DECISIONS WHEN THEY'RE TRYING
TO BROTHER COMPANY AND GROW
THE ECONOMY HERE IN CALIFORNIA
WHEN THERE'S UNCERTAINTY OVER
STATE TAX POLICY OVER HOW TAXES
WILL BE CALCULATED AND LEVY
THIS TO TURNER'S DISCRETIONARY
INVESTMENTS IN OUR STATE THAT
HURTS CALIFORNIA THAT COST US
JOBS IN THE COST OF FUTURE TAX
REVENUE THE DECISION BY THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE GOVERNOR TO
SUSPEND THE OTHER WELL FOR THREE
YEARS -- BECAUSE OF THE COVERT
NINETEEN EMERGENCY ABSOLUTELY
MADE SENSE AT THE TIME HOWEVER
AS IT IS TURNED OUT WE NOW
KNOW THAT THE SUSPENSIONS
WERE ENTIRELY UNNECESSARY
IN FACT OVER THE LAST TWO
FISCAL YEARS ACCORDING TO THE
NONPARTISAN LEGISLATIVE ANALYSTS
AND TO THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
THERE HAVE BEEN GENERAL FUND
SURPLUSES EXCEEDING ONE HUNDRED
BILLION DOLLARS AND THERE
ARE RECORD SURPLUSES THAT ARE
EXPECTED AGAIN THIS YEAR ALL
RIGHT NOW I THINK THE ESTIMATE
IS FORTY FIVE BILLION AND
COUNTING MY CLIENT LIKE MANY
OTHER CALIFORNIA COMPANIES WAS
PERFECTLY WILLING TO PROVIDE A
GENERAL FUND ZERO INTEREST LOAN
FOR THREE YEARS UNDER THE BELIEF
THAT THE STATE NEEDED THE FUNDS
AND WITH THE EXPECTATION THAT AT
SOME POINT THEY COULD ACTUALLY
RECOUP THESE TAX BENEFITS IN THE
FUTURE BUT WE KNOW NOW
THAT THE NFL SUSPENSION WAS
NOT NECESSARY FOR COMPANIES
LIKE MY CLIENT AND FOR OTHERS
HERE IN CALIFORNIA AND FOR
SOME PEOPLE THEY WILL NEVER BE
ABLE TO RECOUP THE INVESTMENTS
THEY MADE AS A RESULT OF THE
SENATE WILL SUSPENSIONS SB
ONE THIRTEEN ENACTED EARLIER
THIS YEAR REMOVES THE END OF
ALL SUSPENSION FOR THE TWENTY
TWENTY TO FISCAL ARCHITECTURE
BUT WE NEED ASSEMBLY WOMAN
RUBIO'S BILL IN ORDER TO ADDRESS
THE TWENTY TWENTY AND TWENTY
TWENTY ONE TAX YEARS WE BELIEVE
THAT ALL CALIFORNIA TAXPAYERS
WHO MADE ZERO INTEREST LOANS
TO THE STATE GENERAL FUND AS
A RESULT OF AB EIGHTY FIVE
THE TRAILER BILL THAT SET
THIS UP WITH AS WE BELIEVE
THAT THEY DESERVE TO BE MADE
WHOLE NOW THE CALIFORNIA HAS
EXPERIENCED UNPRECEDENTED
GENERAL FUND SURPLUSES OVER
THE LAST TWO YEARS MAKING THE
ORIGINAL NEED FOR THE SUSPENSION
POINTLESS FOR ALL THESE REASONS
WE SUPPORT AB TWENTY SIXTY
FIVE WE THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
HER LEADERSHIP AND WE WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE WHEN THIS DOES COME UP
FOR VOTE IN COMMITTEE LATER
THIS MONTH THANK YOU MANAGER
QUICK TURNAROUND MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS -- BEHALF OF CRAWLER GM
ATTACKS DURING A MOSTLY HERE TO
ANSWER QUESTIONS IF THERE ARE
ANY -- I GUESS OLD ADD TO ONE
ADDITIONAL PIECE TO THE POLICY
QUESTION WHICH IS THE NATURE OF
THE IN A WELL WE'RE TRYING TO
REALLY CONNECT TO THE H. OF THE
INCOME TAX TRYING TO CONNECT
THOSE EXPENSES THAT EARNED
INCOME MONTHS YOU KNOW THAT
USUALLY HAPPENS OVER BUSINESS
CYCLE -- IN THIS CONTEXT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT IS NOT NEW NEW
LOSSES FROM -- AND NEW ID X.
-- INVESTMENT TALKING ABOUT --
-- THE EXPENSES WERE SUSPENDED
AS A RESULT OF THE -- BUDGET
ACTIONS FROM A COUPLE YEARS
AGO SO IT IS A CARRY BACK BUT
NOT IN THE TRADITIONAL SENSE
OF LIKE WE USED TO ALLOW AN O.
L. KERRY BACK -- AND SO FROM
THAT PERSPECTIVE WE'RE REALLY
TRYING TO MAKE SOME TAXPAYERS
WHOLE WHO WERE IN OPPOSITION
OF HAVING A SUBSTANTIAL SALE
SO I CAN ANSWERING QUESTIONS
TERMS THE TECHNICAL LANGUAGE
IF YOU HAVEN'T SO THAT'S ALL
I HAVE TO I TESTED WAS IT
EXCELLENT TERMS OF THE NATURE
OF THE BILL THANK YOU ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU DO WE HAVE ANY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT IN THE ROOM
OF
THE MODERATOR PLEASE OPEN THE
LINE FOR SUPPORTING TESTIMONY
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO ON YOUR TELEPHONE KEYPAD
WE DO HAVE MULTIPLE LINES
GIVING UP ONE MOMENT PLEASE
FIRST WE'RE GOING TO LINE SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS DATE OR JUST ON
BEHALF OF THE FAMILY BUSINESS
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT AND REQUESTING YOUR
SUPPORT AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME
EXCELLENT I'M THIRTY YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD
LAWRENCE GATE KNOW ABOUT
THE CALIFORNIA MANUFACTURING
TECHNOLOGY ASSOCIATION RECALL
IT IS WRONG TO PORT THANK YOU
OVERLAND TWENTY NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD
THANK YOU KRISTIN YOUNG
THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE HERE IN SUPPORT
ONE MOMENT PLEASE LO
PRED MORE LINE NUMBERS
TOTALING TWENTY ONE LINE IS OPEN
REXHEPI HI MY BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA BUSINESS PROPERTIES
THIS YEAR XIN BUILDING OWNERS
AND MANAGERS ASSOCIATION
CALIFORNIA AND NOW CALIFORNIANS
SUPPORT THANK YOU OR
TOTALING NINE MILLION
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD
GOOD AFTERNOON BENTLEY
WITH THE COMPANY TAXPAYERS
ASSOCIATION SUPPORT THANK YOU
I HAVE NO ADDITIONAL LINES AT
THIS TIME ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU DO WE HAVE ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
DO WE HAVE ANYBODY ON
THE LINE IN OPPOSITION
CONDEMNING THE SIGNUP
POSSESSION PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME
NO LINE THANK YOU AT THIS TIME
ALL RIGHTS DO WE HAVE QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS OF THE COMMITTEE
THIS FEATURE THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR I AND I JUST HAVE A
COMMENT REALLY -- WHEN I FIRST
I THINK THINK THE AUTHOR FOR
BRINGING THIS MEASURE FORWARD
I THINK IT'S VERY IMPORTANT I'M
YOU KNOW IT SEEMS TO ME THAT'S
VERY HARD TO ARGUE WITH THE
FACT THAT IN IN AN AREA WHERE
WE HAVE A SURPLUS ONE OF THE
FIRST THINGS WE SHOULD DO WITH
THAT SURPLUS IS EFFECTIVELY
PAY DOWN I THINK YOUR WITNESS
SCRIBE IS THE ZERO INTEREST
LOANS THAT -- WE RECEIVED IN
A MOMENT WE THOUGHT WE ARE
FACING A DEFICIT I'M AND THEN I
ALSO JUST WANT TO -- HONED
IN ON ANOTHER POINT THAT YOU
MADE WHICH I THINK IS RELEVANT
TO THIS BUT I THINK I'M ALSO
RELEVANT TO OUR TAX POLICY MORE
BROADLY WHICH IS AROUND JUST
THE IMPORTANCE OF CERTAINTY
I'VE FORWARD AND NOT JUST YOUR
COMPANY BUT YOU COMPANIES LARGE
AND VERY SMALL ACROSS THE STATE
AND -- I THINK THAT THAT IS
SUCH AN IMPORTANT POINT WE HAVE
TO ENSURE THAT ODD BUSINESSES
FEEL LIKE THEY CAN CONTRAST OUR
POLICIES ARE GOING TO REMAIN
CONSISTENT AND THAT THEY CAN
MAKE INVESTMENTS AND DECISIONS
AND CREATE JOBS ON THAT BASIS SO
-- THANK YOU FOR THAT POINT AND
I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT ONE AS WE
MOVE THROUGH AS OUR SUSPENSE
FILE AS WELL THANK YOU THANK YOU
I -- APPRECIATE --
HIS PETRIE-NORRIS HIS COMMENTS
ALL RIGHT I WONDER DO
WE KNOW OF ANY OTHER COMPANIES
THAT WOULD BENEFIT FROM THIS
BECAUSE CERTAINLY WE WOULDN'T
WANT TO LOOK LIKE WE'RE DOING
LEGISLATION FOR JUST ONE COMPANY
SO DO WE DO WE HAVE
OTHER COMPANIES TO APPLY TO
WITHOUT THE AUTHOR'S PERMISSION
-- SO I'VE HAD THIS DISCUSSION
WITH YOUR COUNSEL MISTER RUFF
THERE IS ONE OTHER COMPANY
THAT I DIRECTLY KNOWLEDGEABLE
ABOUT -- IT'S NOT AND IT'S NOT
-- HERE SAY AT A BECAUSE I WAS
CONTACTED BY A FARMER IN HIS
MID SIXTY SEVEN HIS WIFE IN THE
CPA I WAS CONTACTED BY THEM IN
OCTOBER WONDER IF THEY'RE GOING
TO BE ANY MORE AMENDMENTS TO
MISS RUBIO SAY B. TWO TWENTY
TWO FROM LAST YEAR AND --
M. HIS SITUATION WAS THAT HE
HAD BEEN IN THE FOR HIS FAMILY'S
FAMILY FARM OPERATION NOT A
BIG FARMER BUT YOU KNOW THE OWN
THREE BIG PARCELS OF LAND IN THE
SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY THE CENTRAL
VALLEY AND -- BECAUSE FORMING
SO TOUGH THIS IS TO BE IN THE
DROUGHT WATER SHORTAGES AND
EVERYTHING YOU'VE BEEN LOSING
MONEY HIS PRODUCTION CREDIT
ASSOCIATION HE WAS HE WAS IN
A REAR SOME PAYMENTS AND THEY
WERE GONNA FORECLOSE IF YOU DID
RAISE CAPITAL AND SO WHAT HE
DID IN TWENTY TWENTY C. TOOK THE
PARCEL OF LAND THAT HAVE BEEN
IN THE FAMILY THE LONGEST WHICH
THEY OWN FREE AND CLEAR AND YOU
SOLD IT BECAUSE HE NEEDED THE
MONEY TO PAY OFF THE PRODUCTION
CREDIT ASSOCIATION TO STAY
IN BUSINESS AND OF COURSE HE
DIDN'T REALIZE AT THE TIME --
BECAUSE HE DOESN'T PAY LOBBYIST
LIKE ME UP IN SACRAMENTO GIVEN
REPORTS EVERY MONTH BUT HE
DIDN'T REALIZE THE TIME THAT
HIS AND A WELL OF THE STATE
ALL THOSE LOSSES EVEN CARRIED
ON THE BOOKS IT WAS DRIVING
THIS DECISION HE COULDN'T USE
SO HIS TAX BILL ENDED UP BEING
OVER I THINK WAS A HUNDRED AND
SIXTY FOUR HUNDRED AND SEVENTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS HIGHER THAN IT
WOULD HAVE BEEN AND THAT'S MONEY
THAT HE GOT A PUT BACK INTO HIS
FARM A RATHER THAN HAVE TO PAY
FRANCHISE TAX BOARD NOW HE'S
NEVER GOING TO GET A CHANCE TO
MAKE THAT BACK UP BECAUSE YOU
KNOW THE FARMING IS WHAT IT IS
AND HE'S GETTING ON IN LIFE SO
THAT'S ANOTHER DIRECT EXAMPLE
I CAN TELL YOU MADAM CHAIR OF
SOMEBODY THAT I SPOKE DIRECTLY
WITH ON THIS MATTER AND I'M AND
I KNOW THERE ARE OTHERS LIKE
THAT YEAH I AND AND IT WOULD
BE HELPFUL TO KNOW I KNOW THERE
WERE A LOT OF SUPPORTERS ON
THE LINE WE HAVE THE CHAMBER
AND THE MANUFACTURERS AND --
MAYBE YOU CAN ASK THEM IF
THEY KNOW ABOUT CASES BECAUSE
AS I SAID -- THAT IT WE
DON'T WANT IT SAID LOOK LIKE
LEGISLATION IS JUST BENEFITING
ONE TWO PEOPLE -- I'D DIE
SO -- I I WOULD URGE YOU TO
REACH OUT A LITTLE BIT MORE AND
GIVE US SOME SOME ADDITIONAL
-- EXAMPLES BECAUSE WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT YOU'RE SUCCESSFUL
WITH THIS BILL THANK YOU
ALL RIGHT A NEWS RUBIO
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
ABSOLUTELY THANK YOU -- MANAGER
AND I WANT TO THANK -- YOU KNOW
MOST OF YOU HERE WELL ALL OF
YOU HERE WERE ACQUIRED LEADING
THE CHARGE AND THE AND I'LL TAX
I KNOW -- IT'S AT PETRIE-NORRIS
WAS -- ADVOCATING WHEN WE WERE
PASSING SB ONE THIRTEEN AND I
THINK THIS IS JUST AN EXTENSION
AND YOU KNOW TO YOUR POINT WE
DON'T I HAVE MY INTENT WAS NOT
TO PROTECT JUST ONE COMPANY MY
HOPE IS THAT DIED BECAUSE
WE DO THIS THEN MORE COMPANIES
TO BE LIKE HEY WAIT A MINUTE I
YOU KNOW WE ALSO QUALIFY AND I
YOU KNOW I I THINK THAT'S -- UP
IN THE AIR AND I THINK THAT'S
THE QUESTION HOWEVER IF WE DO
SOMETHING -- THAT IS MEANINGFUL
PERHAPS WE CAN -- YOU KNOW
TALK TO THOSE ORGANIZATIONS
AND SEE IF THEY THERE'S OTHERS
AND I AM CERTAIN THAT THERE IS
I DON'T THINK THAT THAT TIME
WHAT WE DID ON THE AND ALL TAX
WAS YOU KNOW ONLY HARM TO ONE
PARTICULAR COMPANY SOLD THE THE
HOPE IS THAT IF WE WHEN WE DO
REACH OUT TO THOSE ORGANIZATIONS
THAT THEY AT LEAST CAN -- HELP
RECRUIT THEM TO LET THEM LET
US KNOW -- THEIR STORY BECAUSE
AGAIN I MY INTENT IS NOT FOR
ONE COMPANY I THINK THE INTENT
IS FOR RELIEF FOR THOSE FIVE
FOLKS THAT DIED DID INVEST
IN CALIFORNIA AT THAT TIME AND
WE YOU KNOW LOST OUT ON THE AND
ALL TAX SO THANK YOUNG WITH THAT
I WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION IN THE
BOOK I VOTE WHEN DID TIME IS
APPROPRIATE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RUBIO THANK YOU
GENTLEMEN THANK YOU SEE RIGHT WE
ARE GOING TO MOVE BACK TO FILE
ITEM THREE A. B. EIGHTEEN SIXTY
ONE AND -- ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BRIAN WHENEVER YOU'RE READY
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS FIRST I WANT TO
SHALL BE EXITING THE COMMITTEES
AMENDMENTS AND I WANT TO THANK
THE COMMITTEE FOR WORKING SO
CLOSE TO MY TEAM TO GET THIS
RIGHT AND ALSO LIKE TO THANK
THE CHAIR FOR HER LEADERSHIP
TODAY RICE WAS AB EIGHTEEN
SIXTY ONE WHICH ESTABLISHES A
HIRING TAX CREDIT FOR QUALIFIED
EMPLOYERS THE PRIORITIZE HIRING
CALIFORNIA'S FOSTER YOUTH
THIS BILL FOR TECHNICAL SMART
BECAUSE THE FOCUS ON ONE OF
CALIFORNIA FOCUS ON ONE OF
CALIFORNIA'S BIGGEST POLICY
ISSUES AS RELATES TO CHILD
WELFARE SYSTEM HOW DO WE AS
POLICYMAKERS ENSURE THAT FOSTER
YOUTH HAVE THE PROPER SUPPORT
THAT THEY NEED AS THEY AGE OUT
OF THE FOSSEY SYSTEM ENJOY THE
LABOR MARKET DATA SHOWS THAT
CALIFORNIA'S OVER SIXTY THOUSAND
FOSTER YOUTH WITH THE THIRD
LIVING IN L. A. COUNTY ALONE ALL
OF WHOM WILL AGE OUT OF TWENTY
ONE YEARS OLD EVERY YEAR ROUGHLY
FOUR THOUSAND CHILDREN AGE
OUT OF FOSTER CARE SYSTEM MANY
WITHOUT THE PARENTAL SUPPORT
OR KNOW HOW OF HOW THEY'RE
GONNA SUPPORT THEMSELVES
FINANCIALLY WITH A NUMBER OF
UNSTABLE TRANSITIONS AND IN A
FOSTER CHILD'S LIFE CHAU FROM
INTO PHYSICAL ABUSE NEGLECT CAN
CREATE ADDITIONAL BARRIERS TO
MAKE A TRANSITION OUT OF FOSTER
HOME VERY DIFFICULT ACCORDING
TO WALDEN FAMILY SERVICES SIXTY
FIVE PERCENT LEAVE FOSTER CARE
AT AGE EIGHTEEN WITH NO PLACE TO
CALL HOME THAT'S FOUR THOUSAND
POTENTIAL TEACHERS DOCTORS
LAWYERS TECHNICIANS LAWMAKERS
ADVOCATES BELIEVE THE SYSTEM
EVERY YEAR WHO'S DOING HELP
TRANSITIONING INTO ADULTHOOD
WE KNOW THE FUSS YOU SUFFER FOR
SOME THE WORST EMPLOYMENT AND
SELF SUFFICIENCY OUTCOMES OF
ANY POPULATION IN OUR COUNTRY
WHEN CHILDREN AGE OUT OF THE
TWENTY PERCENT OF THEM END UP
HOMELESS WITHIN THAT FIRST YEAR
FOR MANY IT WILL NEVER BE IT
WILL BE A NEVER ENDING CYCLE
OF CHRONIC POVERTY HOMELESSNESS
AND STRUGGLE THROUGH THEIR ADULT
WE CAN DO IS LEGISLATORS
TO ADDRESS CHALLENGES PASS
AB EIGHTEEN SIXTY ONE WHICH
ESTABLISHES A TAX CREDIT OF
UP TO TEN THOUSAND DOLLARS PER
L. ELIGIBLE FOSTER YOUTH PER
YEAR TO INCENTIVIZE BUSINESSES
TO SPECIFICALLY HIGHER
TRANSITION AGE FOSTER YOUTH
CREATING CRITICAL EMPLOYMENT
OPPORTUNITIES FOR THESE YOUNG
PEOPLE RESEARCH CELLS THAT
INDIVIDUAL EXPERIENCES EARLY
UNEMPLOYMENT IS MORE LIKELY TO
HAVE LOWER FUTURE EARNINGS IN
ADDITION FOR REPEATED PERIODS OF
JOBLESSNESS RIGHT NOW WE HAVE
BOTH A LABOR AND A WAIT SHORTAGE
HAPPENING SIMULTANEOUSLY WITH
THIS BILL WILL DO IS EMPOWER
EMPLOYERS TO OFFER GAINFUL WAGES
DO YOU FOR COMING OUT OF THE
CHILD WELFARE SYSTEM AND ALSO
A MITIGATE THE COSTS OF NEW
PEOPLE COMING INTO THE WORKFORCE
NEEDING THAT GAINFUL EMPLOYMENT
WITH ME TODAY THE CEO
AND CO FOUNDER BY FOSTER'S
THREE TO THAT IS HERE TO TESTIFY
THANK YOU AND AT THANK
YOU COMMITTEE MEMBERS YES MY
NAME IS RITA CAUCUS I AM THE
CEO AND CO FOUNDER OF AYE
FOSTER AYE FOSTERS A NATIONAL
NONPROFIT SERVING CHILDREN YOUTH
AND KAREN WERE BASED HERE IN
CALIFORNIA I ALSO HAPPEN TO BE A
FORMER FOSTER YOUTH I FOSTER
IS ARGUABLY ONE OF THE LARGEST
EMPLOYERS OF FOSTER YOUTH IN
THE STATE -- WE EMPLOY ABOUT
A HUNDRED AND TWENTY FOSTER
YOUTH ANNUALLY AND TEN MONTH
INTERNSHIPS AND WE WORK WITH
OVER A HUNDRED NATIONAL AND
REGIONAL MAJOR EMPLOYERS FOR
PERMANENT JOB EMPLOYMENT FOR ON
AVERAGE ABOUT TWO HUNDRED AND
FIFTY CALIFORNIA FOSTER YOUTH
EVERY YEAR -- SO WE'VE LEARNED A
FEW THINGS EVEN AT THIS
TIME WHERE ARE YOU BELIEVE
IF YOU ARE BREATHING YOU CAN
GET A JOB ARE YOU STILL STRUGGLE
TO GAIN FOOTHILL FOOTHOLDS
INTO PROFESSIONAL CAREERS AND TO
RETAIN EMPLOYMENT EVEN IN
THE MOST ENTRY LEVEL JOBS JUST
LIKE ASSEMBLY MEMBER BRIAN SAID
I ARE YOU SPACE BARRIERS IN
THOSE BERRIES DON'T NECESSARILY
GO AWAY WITHIN YOUR FIRST FEW
WEEKS OR MONTHS OF EMPLOYMENT
OUR USER NOT GIVEN THE
OPPORTUNITY TO FAIL UP WHICH
IS WHY SUPPORT OF PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT IS CRITICAL AS IS
EMPLOYERS WHO ARE OPEN TO TAKING
ON HIRES TO MODERATE WHO MIGHT
SUFFER SETBACKS OR BARRIERS
OVER THE WEEKS AND EVEN MONTHS
AFTER THEY'VE BEEN HIRED AS
THE AGE OUT OF THE SYSTEM AND
LEARN TO BECOME SELF SUFFICIENT
BUT EMPLOYERS NEED TO HAVE AN
INCENTIVE TO DO THAT THEY ARE
IN A FOR PROFIT BUSINESS WHY
FOSTER YOUTH I AS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BRIAN ALREADY MENTION
FOSTER YOUTH WHO BY THE WAY
ARE WARDS OF THE STATE ARE
THEY ARE OUR RESPONSIBILITY
SUFFERED THE WORST EMPLOYMENT
AND SELF SUFFICIENCY
OUTCOMES OF ANY CALIFORNIA
YOUNG RESIDENTS WITHIN FOUR
YEARS HOW AWFUL EXPERIENCE
HOMELESSNESS HALF WILL BE
UNEMPLOYED AND THOSE THAT
ARE EMPLOYED ARE ONLY EARNING
SEVENTY FIVE HUNDRED A YEAR
AND WHY TAX CREDIT
AS I MENTIONED WE PARTNER WITH
OVER A HUNDRED NATIONAL AND
REGIONAL EMPLOYERS ACROSS RETAIL
SUPPLY CHAIN GROCERY HEALTHCARE
TECH AND BUSINESS OPERATIONS
WHEN ASKED WHAT WOULD YOU WHAT
DO YOU NEED AS AN INCENTIVE
TO INVEST IN FOSTER YOUTH
IT'S NOT O. J. T. IT'S NOT
HOSTING INTERNS I IT IS
ACTUALLY GETTING A TAX CREDIT
SO AB EIGHTEEN SIXTY ONE IS
AN IMPORTANT PIECE IN ENSURING
THAT OUR FOSTER YOUTH ATTAIN
SELF SUFFICIENCY YES THERE IS
INTERNSHIPS APPRENTICESHIPS
WE NEED TO INVEST IN JOB SKILL
TRAINING FOR OUR YOUNG PEOPLE SO
THAT THEY'RE READY BUT WE NEED
EMPLOYERS TO COME ALONG SIDE
US AND THAT'S WHERE AB EIGHTEEN
SIXTY ONE COMES INTO A FACT
IT DOES MIRROR LEGISLATION THAT
WAS ALREADY PASSED LAST YEAR
THE HOMELESS HIRING TAX CREDIT
BUT SERIOUSLY WE DON'T NEED TO
WAIT TILL OUR YOUTH ARE HOMELESS
FOR THEM TO GET A TAX CREDIT
FOR OUR EMPLOYEES TO GET TAX
CREDITS THIS BILL IS CRITICAL
IN LOVE IN LEVELING THE
PLAYING FIELD FOR FOSTER YOUTH
AND I URGE YOU TO SUPPORT ITS
PASSAGE AND THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR TIME THANK YOU
-- JUST FOR TECHNICAL OF
FOR QUESTIONS ALRIGHT --
LET'S SEE DO WE HAVE AND
THE WITNESS I DO DO WE HAVE
ANYBODY IN SUPPORT IN THE ROOM
AND CAN WE HAVE THE MODERATOR
OPEN THE LINES FOR US
SUPPORTING TESTIMONY PLEASE
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO ON YOUR TELEPHONE KEYPAD
GO TO OUR FIRST LINE MY
NUMBER THIRTY FOUR LANE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD YEAH
I CAN LIVE WITH REPRESENTING
THAT CALIFORNIA COALITION
FOR YEARS AND NOT IMPORTANT
WE HAVE NO ADDITIONAL LINES
AT THIS TIME ALL RIGHT
-- DO WE HAVE ANY WITNESSES
IN THE ROOM THAT WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
MODERATOR ARE THERE ANY OF THE
SPEAKERS THAT HAVE OPPOSITION
TESTIMONY ON THE LINE FOR
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME
ONE MOMENT PLEASE ONLY
PROVIDE A LINE NUMBER
WHAT A LINE NUMBER TWENTY
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD GOOD AFTERNOON COMMITTEE
MEMBERS THIS IS THE OTHER NAME
A YOUNG WITH POLITICAL SOLUTION
CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE ALAMEDA
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL THANK YOU
NO ADDITIONAL LINE THANK YOU
AT THIS TIME AND I WILL
NOTE THAT THAT WAS -- IN SUPPORT
OF YOUR BILL I WAS WAITING
TO SEE WHO WOULD ACTUALLY
-- SPEAK AGAINST IT SOUTH
ALREADY ALL RIGHT QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE
THIS GRAYSON THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR I WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD
YOUNG PEOPLE AND CHILDREN THAT
GREW UP IN TRADITIONAL HOMES
CONTINUE TO HAVE A SUPPORT --
A FOUND A SUPPORT FOUNDATION
EVEN AFTER THE AGE OF TWENTY
ONE -- I KNOW THAT PERSONALLY
AND -- BUT STILL A PROVIDE
MUCH SUPPORT TO TO MY CHILDREN
HOWEVER FOR FOSTER YOUTH ONCE
THEY REACH THAT THRESHOLD OF
TWENTY ONE SO MANY OF THEM
ARE LEFT ALONE OR FOR SICK AND
THEY'RE OUT ON THEIR OWN AND THE
LAST THING THEY NEED IS IS --
FOR US TO TURN OUR BACK ON THEM
WHO HAVE PROVIDED SUPPORT FOR
THEM THROUGHOUT THEIR UPBRINGING
SO WITH THAT I JUST WANTED TO
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR THINKING
ABOUT THIS AND FOR THE -- FOR
THE SUPPORT THAT YOU HAVE FROM
YOUR SPONSORS TO A REALLY MAKE
SURE THAT WE PROVIDE THE MUCH
NEEDED SUPPORT GOING FORWARD
AND IF THAT MEANS OPENING AND
OPENING UP AN OPPORTUNITY TO
DOOR FOR THEM TO CONTINUE IN
EMPLOYMENT -- THAT IS HUGE
IN THEIR FUTURE SUCCESS AT
LEAST WE KNOW THAT FROM DATA
AND FROM STATISTICS THANK
YOU THANK YOU ASSEMBLYMEMBER
GRAYSON ANY OTHER COMMENTS
ALL RIGHT WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE YES A
THANK YOU FOR YOUR COMMENTS
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT IS ECONOMIC
OPPORTUNITY IMMOBILITY ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT'S IMPORTANT ME
AS WELL AS OUR PROBLEM NINETY
EIGHT DOLLARS AND I EDUCATION
DOLLARS AND NOT TAKING FROM
THOSE EXCEPT THIS YEAR WE HAVE A
ROBUST SURPLUS FOR THE SECOND
YEAR IN A ROW THIS IS A ONE TIME
THIRTY MILLION DOLLAR ALLOCATION
TO PILOT WHEN IT'S GONE IT'S
GONE BUT THE DATA WE GET FROM IT
ON HOW IT IMPROVES THE LIVES OF
YOUNG PEOPLE TRANSITIONING INTO
ADULTHOOD MIKE SHAPE THE WAY WE
THINK OF OUR CIVIC INSTITUTIONS
MORE BROADLY I THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME TODAY THIS COMMITTEE
I KNOW IT'S NOT A VOTING DAY
BUT WHEN IT IS I RESPECTFULLY
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION THANK YOU AND WE
ARE FOR A MOMENT GOING TO
SKIP ITEM SEVEN AND MOVED TO
ITEM NINE MISTER BOTH HEALTH
SORRY IF THAT WAS A SURPRISE
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS FIRST I'D LIKE TO THANK
THE COMMITTEE AND THE COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR THEIR HARD WORK ON
THIS LEGISLATION WE'VE BEEN
WORKING ON THIS FOR AWHILE
AB SEVENTEEN TWENTY NINE WOULD
ALLOW EMPLOYERS TO ASSIST
EMPLOYEES WHAT REPAYMENT OF
THEIR STUDENT LOANS CALIFORNIA
TAX FREE TO THE EMPLOYEE
SO A LOT OF ROOM FOR
YEARS WILL PAY OFF STUDENT
LOANS AND IT'S PART OF THE
INCENTIVE IS PART OF TOWN
THE EMPLOYEE BENEFITS TO
HIRE EMPLOYEES THAT ACTUALLY
SHOW UP FOR WORK CALL
THE ESPECIALLY IN THIS ECONOMY
NOW FROM TWO THOUSAND
TWENTY THREE THROUGH TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY FIVE IT WOULD
PLACE THE LIMIT OF FIVE THOUSAND
TWO HUNDRED FIFTY DOLLARS PER
EMPLOYEE THIS BILL AIMS TO
PROVIDE AN ADDITIONAL OPTION
FOR CALIFORNIA TO ADDRESS THE
STUDENT DEBT CRISIS THAT EXISTS
FOR MANY PEOPLE IN THE STATE
CALIFORNIA IS HOME TO ONE OF
THE LARGEST POPULATIONS OF
STUDENT LOAN DEBT BETWEEN
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN AND TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN OVER FORTY
EIGHT PERCENT OF CALIFORNIA
COLLEGE GRADUATES HAD
STUDENT LOAN DEBT THE NEWEST
GENERATION OF COLLEGE GRADUATES
IS SADDLED WITH SIX TIMES
MORE DEBT THAN THEIR PARENTS
AND WAGES HAVE NOT INCREASED
AT THE SAME LEVELS PLUS
INFORMATION THE GOVERNMENT
SAYS INFLATION IS SEVEN
POINT EIGHT PERCENT
I THINK IT'S AROUND ELEVEN
PERCENT BUT SILLY ME
NATIONALLY
STUDENT DEBT IS ONE POINT
FIVE FOUR TRILLION DOLLARS
AS OF JUNE TWENTY TWENTY
ACCORDING TO THE FEDERAL
RESERVE BANK OF NEW YORK
WELL WHAT WOULD HAPPEN
EXCUSE ME THAT AND PLEASE
PLEASE THAT YOU SCARED ME
WELL THE STUDENT LOAN REPAYMENT
PLAN IS CURRENTLY OFFERED BY
MANY EMPLOYERS IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA BOTH IN THE
PUBLIC AND PRIVATE SECTORS
THE PROGRAM HELPS ALLEVIATE
AND MINIMIZE THE EXISTING
DEBT THAT AN EMPLOYEE MUST PAY
WE ARE ALREADY ALLOWING THIS
TAX BENEFIT FOR CONTINUING
EDUCATION SO THIS IS A NEW
THIS IS JUST HELPING MORE
AB SEVENTY TWENTY NINE WOULD
HELP EMPLOYERS TO ATTRACT
WORKERS AND WOULD ALLOW THOSE
WITH STUDENT DEBT TO BE
ABLE TO SAVE FOR THE FUTURE
WHEN THEY ARE RELIEVED OF A
PORTION OF THAT BURDEN A TWO
THOUSAND SIXTEEN LENDING TREE
REPORT STATED THAT FORTY PERCENT
OF MILLENNIALS HAVE NOT SAVED
ANYTHING TOWARDS RETIREMENT
NEAR GRADUATING WITH AN
AVERAGE LOAN OF THIRTY
SEVEN THOUSAND ONE HUNDRED
AND SEVENTY TWO DOLLARS WILL
THAT'S QUITE A CREDIT CARD
CHARGE I'VE READ THE CONCERNS
REGARDING IMPLEMENTATION
FROM THE FRANCHISE TAX BOARD
AND HAVE BROUGHT WITH ME THE
SPONSORS OF THE BILL CAL'S
SHERMAN WHICH IS THE
GURUS OF ALL EMPLOYEE BENEFITS
TO ADDRESS THE ISSUES BROUGHT
FORTH BY THE BOARD WITH
THE CHAIRS PERMISSION I'D LIKE
TO INTRODUCE ALREADY FRIEDMAN
WITH THE SOCIETY FOR HUMAN
RESOURCE MANAGEMENT IF SHE'S ON
THE LINE S.
AND -- IF I AM HERE IT'S
MODERATOR COULD OPEN THE LINE
THAT WILL IF YOU ARE THE ONLY
PERSON THAT IS HAVING -- --
TESTIMONY ONLINE AND YES YOU
DID SPEAK TO US AHEAD OF TIME
SO -- WE ARE HAPPY TO
ACCOMMODATE YOU THANK YOU
HELLO I THINK ONE HEARING
YES WE CAN HEAR YOU LET'S A GUY
OKAY AND GOT SICK HI HI
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE I AM SORRY FRIEDMAN
AND WE RESPECTFULLY REQUEST THE
COMMITTEE SUPPORT OF AB ONE
SEVEN TWO NINE WITH AN IPHONE
AS AN HR PROFESSIONAL TALENT
ACQUISITION THE TIME IS NOW
TO ALLOW EMPLOYERS ADDITIONAL
BENEFITS TO ATTRACT THAT TALENT
THE CURRENT TALENT MARKET CAN'T
MARKET WHICH I DO FIND EXCITING
AND IT'S ARE SEARCHING FOR
THE BEST FIT FOR THEM AND MORE
GRADUATE STUDENTS THAN EVER
BEFORE OFFERING INCENTIVES TO
SUPPORT PAYING OFF STUDENT DEBT
IS AN EASY WIN FOR BOTH THE
EMPLOYER AND EMPLOYEE IT CREATES
A COMPETITIVE ADVANTAGE FOR
EMPLOYERS TO HIRE AND DEVELOP
THE BEST TALENT FOR THEIR NEEDS
FURTHERMORE I AND I AND I AM
ALSO A CURRENT MBA STUDENT AT
USC MARSHALL FIGHT ON -- IT
TAKEN ON STUDENT DEBT IT IS
FANTASTIC THAT GRADUATE LEVEL
EDUCATION MORE ACCESSIBLE FOR
ALL BUT NOW THE STUDENT DEBT
CONTINUES TO RISE THAT WILL PUT
A STRAIN ON MY FAMILY WILL CUT
US BACK FINANCIALLY WITH AN AYE
VOTE FOR AB ONE SEVEN TWO NINE
THIS WILL ALLOW MY FAMILY AND
MANY OTHERS THE OPPORTUNITY TO A
BETTER LIFE POSTGRADUATE SCHOOL
EMPOWER THE WAY FORWARD TOWARDS
PAYING OFF OUR DEBT WITH NO
SET BACK AGAIN MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME THANK YOU AND
DO YOU HAVE A SECOND WITNESS
I DON'T BELIEVE SO ALL RIGHT SO
DO WE HAVE ANYBODY ON THE LINE
THAT WISHES TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
LADIES AND GENTLEMAN TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO ON YOUR TELEPHONE KEYPAD
NO LINES IN QUEUE AT
THIS TIME ALL RIGHT ANY
WITNESSES IN THE ROOM THAT
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
ANY WITNESSES IN THE ROOM THAT
SWITCH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
ANY WITNESSES ON THE LINE THAT
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN TO SPEAK
IN A POSITION PLEASE PRESS
ONE BUTTON ZERO AT THIS TIME
NO LINES INTO AT THIS TIME
OUR OKAY ANY
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS
FROM THE COMMITTEE
OKAY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
PLEASE S. THIS BILL
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR YOUR PRESENTATION
AND --
MS VALLADARES SORROWS
ARE YOUR WITNESSES HERE
OTHER ON THE LINE OKAY
THIS YEAH
MY OFFICIAL MAKES EVERY READY
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
AND COMMITTEE STAFF FOR YOUR
TIME TODAY AB TWO SIX
TWO ZERO IS AN INNOVATIVE WAY
FOR THE STATE TO INCENTIVIZE
SMALL BUSINESSES TO ALLOW THEIR
EMPLOYEES TO TELECOMMUTE BECAUSE
OF THE COLD NINETEEN PANDEMIC
AND THE STATE'S MANDATED
CLOSURES MANY OF CALIFORNIA
SMALL BUSINESSES AFTER EMPLOYEES
TO WORK REMOTELY THIS SHIFT
IS HOW CALIFORNIANS WORK
PROMPTED A DECREASE IN TRAFFIC
AND A DECREASE IN GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS RELATED TO TRAVEL AND
TWENTY TWENTY REDUCE COMMUTING
HELPS CONTRIBUTE TO A RECORD
DROP OF SEVEN PERCENT AND
GLOBAL CARBON DIOXIDE EMISSIONS
FOR THE FIRST TIME IN OVER A
DECADE GOOGLE MAPS HOW TO UPDATE
THEIR ETA PREDICTIONS BECAUSE OF
A FIFTY PERCENT DROP IN TRAFFIC
WORLDWIDE THESE ARE CHANGES THAT
SHOULD BE ENCOURAGED I DON'T
KNOW ABOUT YOU BUT I HAVE YET
TO MEET A SINGLE PERSON WHO
WANTS MORE TRAFFIC AND HE WANTS
MORE GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS
TO ENCOURAGE BUSINESSES
TO ADOPT TELECOMMUTING AND
HELP CALIFORNIA REDUCE OUR
TRAFFIC AND CARBON FOOTPRINT
I INTRODUCED AB TWO SIX TWO
ZERO WHICH PROVIDE SMALL
BUSINESSES WITH A THOUSAND
DOLLAR TAX CREDIT FOR EACH
EMPLOYEE EMPLOYEE THEY PERMIT
TO WORK REMOTELY THE BILL
ALSO AUTHORIZES THE TRANSFER
OF MONEY FROM THE GREENHOUSE
GAS REDUCTION FUND TO OFFSET
POTENTIAL LOST REVENUE FROM
THE USE OF THIS TAX CREDIT I
DO HAVE ONE WITNESS ON THE LINE
RIGHT MODERATOR HAVE YOU
FIVE FOUND THE WITNESS
WHAT IS THE NAME
WE'RE LOOKING FOR
AB TWO SIX TWO ZERO
OF EXIT MELANIE IS THE
NAME OF THE WITNESS
MELANIE HER ONLINE PRE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
ONE MOMENT PLEASE ALWAYS
CHECK ONLINE TO SEE IF
I ALSO HAVE SEAMY VALLEY
CHAMBER ON THE LINE
NANCY WAS THE VALUE CHAMBER
IF MELANIE ISN'T AVAILABLE
MELANIE RELIANCE
OPEN OKAY THANK
YOU CAN YOU HEAR ME
YES WE CAN HEAR YOU OKAY YEAH
YES THIS IS MELANIE WITH ACTOR
COM I'M A BORDER DIRECTOR ON
THE SCENE VALLEY CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE AND I'M CALLING IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL -- WE
ARE A SMALL BUSINESS THAT --
HAS BEEN WORKING REMOTELY AND SO
FORTH -- WITH THESE ARE
DIFFERENT BILL AFFECTS GOING ON
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
DO WE HAVE ANY OTHER WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT ON THE LINE
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT PLEASE
PRESS ONE TO ZERO AT THIS TIME
WE HAVE NO ADDITIONAL LINE
THANK YOU AT THIS TIME ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU DO WE HAVE ANY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT IN THE ROOM
DO WE HAVE ANY WITNESSES --
IN OPPOSITION ON THE LINE
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO ON YOUR TELEPHONE KEYPAD
WAIT LOW LANSING
HERE AT THIS TIME
ALL RIGHT AND -- ANY WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION IN THE ROOM
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE WHAT THE COMMITTEES
HAVE A REST I'M SORRY I AM
SORRY OKAY WHICH LIKE CLOSES
THANK YOU SO MUCH OF MADAM
CHAIR AND THE COMMITTEE FOR
YOUR HELP AND YOUR SUPPORT
-- WHEN THE COMMITTEE IS ABLE
TO CONSIDER THIS MEASURE FOR
A VOTE I STRONGLY ENCOURAGE
AYE VOTE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR PRESENTATION
AND HOPEFULLY WE'LL
FIND ELENI IF
OUR RIGHTS AND I THINK
THAT OUR LAST OF THE BILL
IS ASSEMBLY MEMBER MULLIN
TRANSACTION
LEGISLATIVE
YOU ARE UP MISTER MULLIN
LAST BUT NOT LEAST
AND THAT IS A VALID INTO
THANK YOU THAT I'M SURE MEMBERS
I WANT TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR
THEIR WORK ON THE MEASURE EXCEPT
THE COMMITTEE MEMON SUGGESTS
IN SECTION F. OF THE ANALYSIS
TO LIMIT THE MEASURE TWO AND
ONLY TWO YEAR EXTENSION AND
TO MAKE SURE THE L. A. -- COMES
BACK WITH A REPORT TO HELP
JUSTIFY ANY ADDITIONAL FUTURE
EXTENSIONS TWENTY SIX TWENTY
TWO SIMPLY EXTENDS AN EXISTING
PARTIAL SALES TAX EXEMPTION
I AUTHORED TWENTY NINETEEN
FOR OUR TRANSIT AGENCIES TO
PURCHASE A ZERO EMISSION BUSES
TRANSIT AGENCIES ARE OFTEN CASH
STRAPPED EVEN MORE SO TODAY WITH
THE RIDERSHIP LOSSES DUE COBIT
EXTENDING THE EXCEPTION OF THE
STATE PORTION OF THE SALES TAX
FOR JABS WILL REDUCE THE UPFRONT
CAPITAL COST AN INCREMENTAL
COST BETWEEN TECHNOLOGIES THUS
DECREASING THE BURDEN ON TRANSIT
AGENCIES ENCOURAGING EARLY
COMPLIANCE WITH THE I. C. T.
R. THE INNOVATIVE CLEAN TRANSIT
REGULATION LEADING TO IMMEDIATE
EMISSIONS REDUCTIONS AND
BENEFITING CALIFORNIANS IN ALL
PARTS OF THE STATE THE BILL IS
BEING PURSUED THIS YEAR SO THAT
TRANSIT AGENCIES HAVE CLARITY ON
THE -- S. U. T. THAT
WOULD APPLY TO SAID PURCHASES
BEGINNING IN TWENTY TWENTY FOUR
AS THEY BEGIN THEIR PROCUREMENT
PROCESS WHICH SOMETIMES -- IS
-- MAYBE THAT SOMETIMES OFTEN
FLANK LENGTHY ANSWER TO EIGHTEEN
TO TWENTY FOUR MONTHS PRIOR
TO THE ISSUANCE OF A PURCHASE
ORDER AND WITH THAT I THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND DEATH
I HAVE TWO WITNESSES TODAY --
-- ALCHEMY GRAHAM LEGISLATIVE
REGULATORY ADVOCATE WITH
THE C. T. A. THE OTHER CTA
THE CALIFORNIA TRANSPOSITION
AND STEPHEN JONES EXTERNAL
AFFAIRS WRAPPED WITH ALAMEDA
CONTRA COSTA TRANSIT DISTRICT
THANK YOU THANK YOU MISSUS
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
NUMBERS ALCHEMY GRAHAM WITH THE
LEFT LEGISLATIVE AND REGULATORY
ADVOCATE WITH THE CALIFORNIA
TRANSIT ASSOCIATION ON BEHALF
OF MORE THAN TWO HUNDRED TWENTY
MEMBER ORGANIZATIONS I'M HERE
TODAY TO VOICE OUR SUPPORT FOR
AND PROUD SPONSORSHIP OF AB
TWENTY SIX TWENTY TWO TODAY
CALIFORNIA'S TRANSIT AGENCIES
ARE TAKING AGGRESSIVE STEPS
TO INTRODUCE ZERO EMISSION
TRANSIT BUS TECHNOLOGIES INTO
THEIR FLEETS FOR STARTERS ALL
TRANSIT BUSES ARE OPERATING IN
CALIFORNIA WILL BE ZERO EMISSION
BY TWENTY FORTY ALIGNING WITH A
ARBY'S INNOVATIVE CLEAN TRANSIT
REGULATION UNFORTUNATELY EVEN
WITH THE ROBUST STATE SUPPORT
OUR AGENCY MEMBERS HAVE BEEN
GRATEFUL TO RECEIVE WE KNOW THAT
THE TRANSITION WILL RESULT IN
NEW COSTS TO TRANSIT AGENCIES
FOR CONTEXT BATTERY CAR BATTERY
ELECTRIC BUSES ARE FORTY TO
SEVENTY PERCENT MORE EXPENSIVE
THAN CONVENTIONALLY FUELED BUSES
WHILE FEEL SPIEL SELL ELECTRIC
BUSES ARE MORE THAN TWICE AS
EXPENSIVE MORE COSTS INCLUDED
THE INSTALLATION OF EXPENSIVE
NEW INFRASTRUCTURE RETRAINING
FOR OPERATORS AND TECHNICIANS
AND HIGHER OPERATING EXPENSES
DUE TO THE PRICE OF ELECTRICITY
AS A FUEL SO TO FULLY COMPLY
WITH THE ICT REGULATION TRANSIT
AGENCIES WILL REQUIRE CONTINUED
AND GROWING STATE SUPPORT
THAT'S WHY AS AN ASSOCIATION WE
HAVE ADVOCATED FOR ADDITIONAL
FUNDING FROM THE STATE BUDGET
AND HELPED PASS AB SEVEN EIGHTY
FOUR IN TWENTY NINETEEN WHICH
FIRST IMPLEMENTED THE SALES TAX
EXEMPTION THAT WE'RE SEEKING
TO EXTEND THROUGH AB TWENTY SIX
TWENTY TWO TODAY WE ESTIMATE
THE SALES TAX EXEMPTION PROVIDED
BY AB SEVEN EIGHTY FOUR HAS
SUPPORTED THE PURCHASE OF JUST
OVER TWO HUNDRED ZERO EMISSION
BUSES AT A TIME WHEN TRANSIT
AGENCIES ARE STILL CHALLENGED
FINANCIALLY BY THE PANDEMIC
WE BELIEVE THAT MEASURES LIKE
AB TWENTY SIX TWENTY TWO ARE
CRITICAL FOR FOR ALLOWING
TRANSIT AGENCIES TO CONTINUE TO
MAKE ADVANCES ON THE SERVICES
THAT THEY PROVIDE ADDITIONALLY
THE TAX EXEMPTION THIS BILL
PROVIDES WOULD AUGMENT THE
SUPPORT THE STATE HAS LONG
PROVIDED TO TRANCE TRANSIT
AGENCIES FOR THEIR MISSION BUSES
ALLOWING TRANSIT AGENCIES TO
BRIDGE A GREATER PORTION OF THE
INCREMENTAL COSTS RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR AYE BUT AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME THANK YOU YEAH
HI GOOD AFTERNOON -- MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
STEVEN JONES EXTERNAL AFFAIRS
REPRESENTATIVE AT THE ALAMEDA
CONTRA COSTA TRANSIT DISTRICT
BASED IN OAKLAND I'M ALSO
SPEAKING IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWO SIX TWO TWO AND I'M HAVE
AC TRANSIT I WANT TO THANK
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MULLIN FOR
INTRODUCING THIS BILL AND THE
COMMITTEE'S CONSIDERATION OF
IT TODAY SINCE TWO THOUSAND
AC TRANSIT HAS BEEN BUILDING
THE MOST COMPREHENSIVE ZERO
EMISSION BUS PROGRAM IN THE
NATION WE CURRENTLY OPERATE
TWENTY SIX ZERO MISSION BUSES
AND THIS YEAR WILL RECEIVE FORTY
ONE MORE INCLUDING TWENTY ONE
BATTERY ELECTRIC AND TWENTY
HYDROGEN POWERED BUSES BRINGING
OUR TOTAL FLEET TO SIXTY SEVEN
ZERO EMISSION BUSES THANKS
TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER -- MULLINS
ORIGINAL BILL AB SEVENTY FOUR AC
TRANSIT HAS REALIZED OVER FORTY
THREE THOUSAND DOLLARS IN TAX
SAVINGS ON EACH HYDROGEN FUEL
CELL BUS PURCHASE AND MORE THAN
THIRTY FOUR THOUSAND DOLLARS
ON THE PURCHASE OF EACH BATTERY
ELECTRIC BUS THIS AMOUNTS TO
OVER SIX HUNDRED EIGHTY SEVEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS IN TAX SAVINGS
JUST ON THE FORTY ONE BUSES THAT
WILL RECEIVE THIS YEAR TO DATE
AC TRANSIT HEADS HAS REALIZED
NEARLY ONE POINT SEVEN MILLION
DOLLARS IN TAX SAVINGS THANKS
TO CURRENT LAW WE'RE USING THE
SAVINGS TO PURCHASE EVEN MORE
ZERO AMEND EMISSION BUSES AND
BUILD THE INFRASTRUCTURE THAT
WILL POWER THEM BUT MORE FUNDING
IS GOING TO BE NEEDED IT WILL
COST AC TRANSIT AN ESTIMATED
ONE POINT ONE BILLION DOLLARS
TO MEET THE STATE MANDATE
REQUIRING TRANSIT OPERATORS
OPERATE ONE HUNDRED PERCENT
ZERO MISSION FLEETS BY TWENTY
FORTY AB TWO SIX TWO TWO
IS A CRITICAL TOOL IN HELPING
US AND OTHER TRANSIT OPERATORS
MEET THIS REQUIREMENT IF
THE CURRENT TAX EXEMPTION IS
EXTENDED FOR ANOTHER TEN YEARS
A. C. TRANSIT COULD REALIZE
TWENTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS IN
TAX SAVINGS AND THIS IS MONEY
THAT CAN BE USED TO BUY MORE
ZERO EMISSION BUSES AND BUILD
OUT THE NEEDED INFRASTRUCTURE
AND WE DO UNDERSTAND THAT THE
COMMITTEE HAS PROPOSED A MORE
LIMITED TIME FRAME FOR THE
EXTENSION WHICH WOULD SCALE
BACK THE COST SAVINGS BUT STILL
MAKE A SUBSTANTIAL PROGRESS
TOWARDS OUR ULTIMATE GOALS
CALIFORNIA'S TRANSIT AGENCIES
CLEARLY NEED MORE FUNDING TO
SEEK TO ACHIEVE ONE HUNDRED
PERCENT ZERO EMISSIONS BY TWENTY
FORTY AB TWO SIX TWO TWO WILL
HELP DELIVER SOME OF THESE
MUCH NEEDED FUNDS AND IT'S ALSO
AN IMPORTANT TOOL IN HELPING
THE STATE MEET ITS AMBITIOUS
CLIMATE GOALS SO I WOULD YOUR
SUPPORT FOR A BI TWO SIX TWO
TWO I THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
RIGHT -- DO WE HAVE ANY
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT OF THE
ROOM YES THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR ABOUT ROBINSON WILSHIRE
INTUITIONISM LYING ON BEHALF
OF THE SAN JOAQUIN REGIONAL
TRANSIT DISTRICT AND MONTEREY
SALINAS TRANSIT IN SUPPORT I
WOULD ALSO NOTE THAT IT WAS MISS
GRAHAM'S FIRST TIME TESTIFYING
IN COMMITTEE TODAY AND I THINK
SHE DID A WONDERFUL JOB VERY
NICE JOB AND SCRAP THANK YOU
THANK YOU -- AND CAN MODERATOR
PLEASE OPEN UP THE LINE
FOR SUPPORTING TESTIMONY
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE THING
HERE ON YOUR TELEPHONE KEYPAD
FIRST TOOK OUT A LINE SIXTEEN
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD
AT NINE AM SHARE MEMBERS
JULIET MELANAU SKI BALL ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ELECTRIC TRANSPORTATION
COALITION IN SUPPORT
HELLO I'M THIRTY SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD
GOOD AFTERNOON HE WALKED
ME UP THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION RECORDED
TRANSPORTATION AND THE BALLOT
RESTORATION THIRTY SUPPORT
THANK YOU AN EXCELLENT
THIRTY SEVEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
COMMITTEE MEMBERS HIGH NEED
TO COLOR OF EMPLOYEE POWER IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY
SIXTY TWENTY TWO THANK YOU
I HAVE NO ADDITIONAL LINES AT
THIS TIME ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
AND IS THERE ANYBODY IN THE ROOM
WISHING TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
NO ANYBODY ON THE LINE
ISN'T AN AMANDA SEEKING A
POSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE BEEN
HERE ON YOUR TELEPHONE KEYPAD
HELLO AND THANK YOU AT THIS TIME
OUR RIGHTS TO ANY QUESTIONS
THANK YOU THAT I I JUST WANT
TO COMMENT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR WORKING WITH THE STAFF
AND UNDERSTANDING THAT IT'S
-- IMPORTANCE TO SEE WHAT
THE EFFECTIVENESS IS OF THE
CREDIT BEFORE WE DO A LONGER
EXTENSION AND AND I'M SURE THE
REPORT WILL BE GLOWING AND --
APPRECIATE -- YOUR
WILLINGNESS TO COMPROMISE
ON THIS ISSUE SO WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE MISSPELLING THANK YOU
MANAGER THANK YOU MEMBERS OF AN
AYE VOTE WHEN I SAW APPROPRIATE
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND GREAT JOB THANK YOU
AND WITH THAT THIS
MEETING IS ADJOURNED